misión está comenzando todos los asistentes están en modo de solo
escucha muy buenas tardes aquí estamos en directo desde ser San Sismas un día
más en la que me parece que es la 12a clase sobre la parte práctica del curso
de trading algorémico bien antes que nada estamos trabajando con la idea
de hacer a ver lo voy a mirar bien lo voy a mirar bien
estamos a nueve verdad que sí todo el día 1 2 3 4 exactamente es decir hacer
además de esta cuatro clases más 4 clases más con la de hoy 5 nos dejaría
hoy es la 12 creo no 13 14 15 nos dejaría con 16 esta es la idea con la
duda de si ya en esa veremos veremos cómo llegamos ahí si ya en esa que sería
la del día 7 lo ya sería una clase podemos decir resumen repaso dudas de
cierre podemos decir o la hacemos después es probable que lo hagamos
después es probable que de organizamos una que a lo mejor puede ser un mes
después de que metidos un poco para repasar dudas para que todo el mundo
acabe que al seguro que haré es porque si es una idea que llevaba de entrada
porque como el ritmo va muy variado gente que va siguiendo gente que no
entonces pienso que puede ir bien dar ese mejor mes de margen para para que
acabe el que no ha acabado y entonces pues ya repasar sus dudas vale bien no
he preguntado si se ve oye bien espero que se me estuviera oyendo
buenas tardes se me oye verdad se oye verdad y si si no se oye verdad mario
vale gracias
el que contesta te oye el que contesta te oye yo lo escribo porque el que no me
oiga no me ha oído esta es la paradoja de las preguntas a veces
o los sesgos o sesgos de las preguntas bueno entiendo que sí entiendo que sí
que todo el mundo me vale este es el
el planning ahora mismo qué más discos vale discos de principio no me consta
tener la pendiente había alguna cosita ahí de debate en el bar y demás he
respondido directamente ahí sobre una función eran temas
que sí que es verdad que lo había dicho había dicho que os la daría y ya digo
de entrada ahora mismo por favor si por eso os doy también ya la un poco una
fecha de acuerdo una fecha de finalización que podría cambiar pero
esperamos que no pero esperamos que no entonces si he dicho cosas que de enviar
que no he enviado todavía sin cualquier cosa a este respecto no tengáis reparo
en poner un mensaje aquí en el curso enviar un email o ponerlo en el disco
que casi es lo más útil para todo el mundo pero cualquier fuente podéis
podéis preguntarlo y os trataremos de responder porque a lo mejor esto por
ejemplo del del aterro dije sé que me queda hacer una una clase al menos de
porfolio gesto monetaria eso se hará y me quedan quedan más cosas en realidad
me quedan muchas más cosas pero claro entenderéis que en algún momento en
algún momento que cortar ya os lo dije no sé si el anterior o demás porque es
que es verdad realmente en algún momento que cortar entonces ya cuando acabemos
yo creo que acabaremos muy bien pero o sea podríamos seguir 250 horas más que
por por por horas de un problema porque puedes estar buscando ideas hay mil
cosas que hacer y esta es la bueno que tiene un curso de teoría económico que
se enfoca para tocar todo donde claro hay tantos temas que tocar que tratas de ir
tocando un día uno un día otro y entonces no me consta tener preguntas si
hay alguna pendiente que me lo recuerde por aquí
interesado interesada pero no me no me consta vale no me consta aquí había el
tema de preguntas y ya estaba creo que todo respondió a espérate está de
alejandro no sé si él se había respondido es verdad está no se había
respondido bueno leo leo un poco leo un poco comentaba alejandro aquí que anda
trasteando en forex que mercado donde nunca ha conseguido encontrar nada
interesante comentaba que los padres contarían suelen ser más sensibles si
bueno el forex la verdad que vale para las dos cosas la verdad que vale para
los dos cosas pero bueno siempre hay más tendencia en más time frame que en menos
vale esto casi es una regla bastante general
es más fácil encontrar tendencia donde se ve más caros en bolsa no aunque es
verdad que en bolsa históricamente es mi reversión pero estos últimos años
hay mucha tendencia también no saque pero claro hay más tendencia en diario
que en intradía también hay pero pero hay más en diario y aquí comentaba
alejandro que tenía esa estrategia
y demás long only en el dólar y en en 15 minutos 725 trades
dice si echarían dar un sistema así podría ser la verdad que sí que es verdad
que sería ideal mejorar todo ese periodo tan largo que dices de cuatro años habría
que estudiarlo un poco y ver pero es verdad que decías que es un tendencial
no ese es un dibujo bastante típico de los tendenciales en intradía es decir
no es fácil conseguir un intradía conseguir un intradía tendencial hormiguita estable
vale esto lo vas a contar más en mil reversión que en tendencial entonces al
final es lo que hablamos siempre si tú si a ti te inspira confianza es robusto etcétera
y tienes ya una cartera y demás pues por lo del portfolio a nivel de análisis ya
haremos como digo al menos una clase de esto y él se aporta al portfolio me explico es decir si
este fuera tu único sistema probablemente no es seguro que no diría pero si tú tienes un
portfolio de estrategias puede ser que aporte al portfolio de hecho es probable que lo haga
vale es probable que lo hagas y en él no hay muchos sistemas de este estilo entonces al final
siempre es ese un poco el punto vale el punto que hay que hay que decir pero que no el comentario
que hace que no gana en cual es un poco triste es cierto pero no es tan extraño en un tendencial
no es tan extraño en un tendencial real o sea claro en backtest es verdad que el tema si eso si
eso fuera live es triste pero aceptable a nivel de portfolio repito como backtest es verdad que
es más duro es más duro es más duro vale la marco la marco responde bien bueno vamos con la
la clase de hoy vamos con la clase de hoy si no hay más dudas bueno a de bueno lo puse en
el disco vale la clase que hice muy breve porque vamos a hablar un poco de vamos a profundizar de
ella la la enseño la comento muy brevemente muy brevemente parte la parte porque ya digo va ligado
totalmente con esto pero pero claro ver para hacerla profundar vale la pena ver ver la ponencia
robotrider que la tenéis ahí en el espera también es que soy aquí está a bueno no ahora no está ahí
perdón mira ahora ahora pili cuando puedas poner en el disco la la el vídeo de youtube de robotrider
vale porque esa ya era para verla en directo y casi mejor en por hoy en material por lo material
por lo material vale material entonces lo que os decía no no la no la vamos a hacer porque sería
un tanto un tanto absurdo pero sí que la la la comento brevemente como como introducción a lo
que vamos a hacer vale porque digamos que es una continuación de esto vale hablamos de la parte que
ya habéis visto de salidas no paro ni un segundo ahí y me voy a centrar un poco en algo que ya
habíais visto y que ya y que ya os he comentado varias veces pero enseñe algún ejemplo enseñe
algún ejemplo práctico y eso es lo que os quería enseñar también había algún tipo y que esto es
lo único que dejo un poco de más pero sobre todo enseñe bastante enseñe bastante el análisis
aparte que es lo que os voy a enseñar ahora vale dedico 5 10 minutos como máximo como máximo vale
como máximo le dedico 5 o 10 minutos por cierto la los que estáis aquí ahora visteis la clase
si alguien me comenta que la vio que no la vio me pareció ver algún alumno por la por el
nombre ahora mismo no sabría deciros cuánto la verdad sí sí sí vale perfecto bueno pues entonces
tengo tres si es de momento no tres si es que hace que hay bastantes que no tengo cuatro si es
venga vamos vamos subiendo parcialmente yo no vale algunos en youtube perfecto bueno ya digo
simplemente enseñar un poco lo de lo del workspace insistir en algo porque es verdad que ahí pues lo
confronté bastante y con el artículo este de andrea hungar hablando de los stops y bueno es
algo que me tiene bastante bueno no sé si la palabra sería sorprendido pero pero bueno ahora
hoy vamos a ver un poco de esto y vamos a trabajar y hay veces que será mejor y a veces que no será
mejor pero pero el tema hoy he tenido que instalar por fin ya sabéis que tuvimos muchos problemas
el último día pero ahora se me está abriendo el cache para pero es igual porque veo que ahora
por lo que sea no tiene los datos en el caché que tiene que descargar y esto pues
puede ser tu match time esto puede ser tu match time a ver que le voy a quitar el link que para
este tema ahora no nos importa para este tema no nos importa y eso va a aligerar de manera
considerable la carga ahora este ahora este ahora este donde donde tenía vos pues este yo me cago
pues no lo tengo la carpeta ahora voy a tener que te voy a hacer el curso alexa baja el volumen el
volumen que lleva su ritmo lo tenía guardado en el curso simplemente para el que no lo viera
os recomiendo ver el vídeo vale recomiendo verla ver la clase esta era donde era más heavy es
exactamente para que vierais este ejercicio que hice comparando simulando un stop porcentual y un
stop monetario que dependiera del máximo anterior vale y entonces pues bueno traté de igualar la
distancia aproximada actual porque es la única en algún sitio tenemos que igualarlo porque parece
que era unos 22 mil o por ahí si por ahí más o menos ves ahí ahí más o menos están parecidos
ahora los puntitos veis ahora precios actual no bueno debería acercarlo un poco más o casi que
se lo alejo más oye porque si no es que está muy cerca le pongo a este 6.1 a 6.3 es 3 por ahí más o
menos no este puntito está ahí ahora bastante parecido bueno para que veas la diferencia que
es obvia y entonces él llegó a la conclusión directamente vale en el de la derecha veis es
porcentual en el de la izquierda es en valor absoluto claro este es un extremo pero pasaba
en más activos no es que más pasas en bolsa a la izquierda llega un momento que esto simplemente
no actúa ahora tú tienes un esto ahora precios actuales que está parecido a la actual es decir
que la relación que va saltando con que no es relativamente similar lógicamente hay alguna
diferencia pero es similar es decir hay puntos amarillos hay puntos rojos cuando es rojos que
ha saltado cuando es amarillo es que no ha saltado vale por arriba y por abajo entonces la relación
es bastante bastante similar con algún pequeño matiz pero ya digo que es similar me parece que
este aulo debería de haber alejado un poquito más debería haber alejado un poquito más y más o
menos ahora ahora es parecido este todo el tiempo mantiene una cierta armonía lógicamente cuando
no hay volatilidad salta menos pero salta como veis también va saltando vale y esto pues provoca
simplemente que el stop el si dimensionamos los stops en períodos un poco antiguos y no hace falta
irse al 2000 aunque te vayas al 2009 o incluso al 2010 incluso al 2012 depende que activo ya
se nota mucho es decir aquí fijaros que ya se nota en el en el 2019 o sea y en el 20 ya no te
cuento en el 12 en cualquier backtest te va a incorporar esos datos vale entonces que está
pasando que yo recordar que ya lo explicaba en la ponencia que recomiendo que veáis y ya
lo sabéis que esto lo he explicado bastantes veces normalmente los el stop rara vez te va a
mejorar el retorno casi todos estos análisis que hacen algunos analistas como el que comenté
andrea ungre se basan en el retorno y el retorno va a ser más en el de la izquierda porque va a
ser más en el de la izquierda porque no saltan esto de acuerdo porque si aquí no hay esto y
sabemos que no tener esto para aumentar el beneficio pues es obvio que es mejor el de la
izquierda pero el hecho de que sea mejor en el sentido de que gane más el hecho mejor dicho el
hecho de que gane más no quiere decir que sea mejor en este caso quiere decir todo lo contrario
y por lo tanto en un en un activo intradiario vale que no haya demasiada variación de precios
puede usarse para el monetario no se trata de decir ahora vais a ver que los hemos puesto también se
trata de decir no no oye nunca monetario vale pero en caso de duda porcentual mejor aún ajustado
por volatilidad vale en caso de dudas siempre ajustado por volatilidad y no se trata de que el
mejor o peor simplemente es más realista es más realista no se trata de conseguir un back test
mejor eso siempre es muy atractivo pero se trata de conseguir un mejor siendo realista y siendo
robusto porque conseguirlo mejor pues es relativamente sencillo acuerdo abajo también se ve porque abajo
tenéis la volatilidad bueno el valor del mercado en porcentaje y a la izquierda en dinero y como
veis pues el de la derecha se mantiene bastante estable dentro de sus lógicas volatilidades
pero veis que tienen niveles picos también un bastante parecidos y fijaros la media de
abajo no la media es esta línea bastante estable vale y aquí pues lógicamente lo es menos que
ahora últimamente ha ido subiendo subiendo porque el precio se lo lleva y ahora pues está viviendo
precios que no ha visto nunca vale cuando estos aquí como veis también los ha visto aquí y
bastante parecidos aquí entonces bueno el de la derecha está normalizado de la izquierda no
entonces no sé a mí me sorprende que todo el mundo hay que normalizar los precios hay que
normalizar los indicadores y en cambio los stops parece que no hay que normalizarlos entonces no
sé es una cosa tremendamente contradictoria y que a mí me sorprende mucho y que digo en absoluto
pongo en duda la calidad técnica de estos traders pero a mí este argumento de verdad no lo entiendo
no lo entiendo y es verdad insisto que hay algunos activos donde se puede hacer sobre todo
editaría y y más pensando en materias primas en demás pero a defenderlo de esta manera a mí
me y no explicar en el artículo esto que os digo yo dice lo lógico es sería lógico ponerlo en
porcentual no no sería lógico luego dice que sería lógico pero que los datos no lo confirman
no lo confirman por lo que te estoy diciendo te estás haciendo unas trampas en solitario como
una catedral porque claro cualquier esto que tú ajustes aquí a la izquierda no va a saltar
imposible en el pasado que la diferencia de precios es tan gigantesca que no no no puede
vale bueno esto me equivocado lo que os digo no no sigo ya ver la ponencia y si alguna
pregunta es vale en cuanto a hoy vale queríamos hablar de salidas tenemos un código bastante
bastante chulo que os voy a que os voy a compartir que es el siguiente vamos a enseñar es un código
de salidas y si lengües antes lengües como bueno tanto tener eso como multicharts tienen
esta particularidad que nosotros a veces usamos y os lo voy a explicar de las dos de las dos
maneras vale vamos a hablar de código pero saber pantalla que nadie que no domine código se asuste
pero aunque he insistido mucho hasta en cuando hablábamos del curso a nivel de marketing que
la programación no es lo más importante en algún momento la parte final antes de empezar
intenté aclararlo porque vi que había mucha gente que estaba entendiendo que no hacía falta
saber programar no no es que no haga falta ser programar lo que no hace falta es ser ingeniero
de programación entiendes pero hay que acabar aprendiendo a programar algo un poco entender
los códigos sobre todo y hacer cosas poco a poco ir creciendo a partir de ahí lo que no lo que no
es es una barrera de entrada que diga o sea es imposible no no hace falta pero sí que hay que
acabar aprendiendo a programar y a esas alturas el full sobre deberíamos de ya chapurrear los que
podernos defender interpretar entender los códigos vale y ya digo con el easy language inicial te
llega y luego con el mastering pues a nivel de easy language super top y si tú sabes spider sabes
otros lenguajes pues perfecto y un problema vale esto es lo mismo en otros lenguajes o sea no es
lo mismo cada lenguaje tiene sus particularidades pero el mismo concepto la misma idea se puede
aplicar si tú sabes python ya te lo sabes aplicar a tu mismo vale entonces al final aquí lo que
creamos son unas unas especies de software que unos códigos que sirven para el desarrollo que
no es el sistema en sí sino es un código totalmente instrumental que sólo está pensado
para desarrollar y que por supuesto le puedes modificar ahora hemos añadido algunos los ya
teníamos algún alguno hecho pero hemos añadido algunos más y posible con el tiempo añadamos
y quitamos otros de acuerdo yo he habido aquí todos los que he podido los que hemos podido y
a mejor hasta nos hemos dejado alguno para poderlos los explicar vale y cómo funciona todo esto vale
fijaros que al final hay cuatro inputs sólo en el sistema los inputs son los parámetros que
te permiten cambiar rápidamente en un gráfico uno que define la entrada otro que define la
salida y luego dos periodos para para cada uno de ellos por si quiere usar un periodo distinto
por el centro lo dejo 22 porque 22 es un mes más o menos vale si va en diario esto viene a
ser parecido a un mes pero da igual tiene mayor mayor e importancia el periodo que es el que
puedes usar 14 pues al 15 es igual a la entrada 0 o de 0 a 7 ahora lo veis que es y salida de 0
a 32 el 0 aunque en la entrada lo he definido para que lo tengáis claro si no lo define es
igual si yo no hubiera puesto un case cero si yo pongo cero no hace nada vale y porque
os digo que esto es muy útil porque yo lo puedo usar a cualquier sistema vale yo lo puedo usar
por ejemplo voy a ir alternando entre gráfico y código para explicaros porque como no puedo
compartir los dos pantallas porque aparte que no bueno no se vería nada de tamaño entonces
yo tengo un código normal es eso si os acordáis bueno son distintas versiones me da igual me
quedo con una que no me importa ahora mismo este si no recuerdo mal es el abe ratio más original
es decir el bollinger tendencial el bollinger tendencial os lo enseño que este es el que está
de hecho lo puse aquí aunque le he llamado le he puesto copiado del tsm bands que es el bollinger
bands que está en el libro este que os he hablado tantas veces de caos vale pero bueno que es el
que vimos que no tiene ninguna ninguna bueno le he añadido de hecho la posibilidad de usar media
normal o media exponencial ya os lo pasaré esto sobre todo por favor cuando digo ya os lo pasaré
toma una toma una nota por eso por eso cuando oigas la frase ya os lo pasaré tiene que
automáticamente saltarte ahí un alarma un alarma los códigos de haber ratio los códigos de haber
ratio porque les hicimos un cambio respecto al que tenía que es una tontería pero para que lo
tenga entonces hay haber ratio de 1 2 y 3 y hasta incluso compilado en uno exportado y todo entonces
la base es la misma si el cierre cierra por encima de la banda alta compra mercado si
cierre cruza la banda baja vende corto a mercado y sale en la media central vale cuando el cierre
cruza la media central para arriba para abajo sale esta es la mecánica normal de haber ratio
entonces aquí os lo voy a explicar en este porque es muy muy sencillo muy intuitivo porque al final
sí que tiene una salida pero tiene una salida como bastante lenta que está el propio sistema
entonces yo le puedo probar otras le puedo probar otras y es aquí donde entra un poco lo que os
decía yo de la gracia de easy language de tres session donde si no si no tampoco tendría bueno
antes lo explico luego lo explico otros casos qué gracia tiene donde yo puedo introducir distintos
códigos en un mismo gráfico y todos se procesan como si fueran una única señal de acuerdo por
lo tanto si yo tengo aquí este sistema de ratio y además introduzco unas salidas esas salidas se
van a procesar normalmente igual que si estuvieran dentro del código sin ninguna diferencia lo único
que tengo que hacer es que no entre que no tomé señales de entrada que si quisiera probar las
entradas podría pero no no en este caso no me interesa porque lo que quiero es añadir más
que añadir quiero probar de manera con un solo código distintas salidas al sistema lo normal
es que no hayan tantas porque esto hasta este día es difícil de manejar pero yo le he puesto
muchas para que lo veáis vale pero lo normal es que no tengas tantas que tengas las 3 4 5 que
a ti te gusten y hasta vale pero pero bueno para que lo veáis y las tengáis todas y os lo pase
pues pues las hemos metido ahí un montón vale hemos metido un montón de salidas pero insisto
que se puede manejar porque al final ya lo veréis como lo hemos hecho pero lógicamente es más
complicado manejar 32 tipos de salida es lo que hay en ese en esa hoja 5 6 32 por son muchos
entonces pero insisto en que está la gracia es esta donde yo simplemente cambiando dejando la
entrada en cero quiere decir que no hace nada y cambiándole esta variable de salida ahora las
veréis tengo 32 poniéndole 0 es ninguna poniéndole una sino le pongo 0 automáticamente veréis que
las líneas verdes y rosas que son las que me marca la salida desaparecerán y seguirá saliendo
por las que salía el sistema normalmente vale su entrada ahora aquí coincide porque ves el cuando
cruza bueno déjame ver que la media las bollinger estén bien tengo puesto 22 también ahí y 22
a nosotros el chandelier vale 22 con dos y perfectamente luego se enseña todo esto
vale 22 sí sí entonces pues abre largos cuando cierra por encima de la banda y cuando perfora la
media central si al cierre lo hace aquí lo que pasa que eso coincide o sea es una vela tan brusca
pues que esto es un gráfico diario que la misma vela que cierra por debajo pero es que esta no lo
hace esta no lo hace por poco vale esta ya cierra por debajo de la media y por debajo de la banda con
lo cual lo que hace es girarse corto y hace girarse girarse corto porque hace las dos cosas a la vez
de acuerdo entonces ya está ahora le he quitado las salidas le he quitado las salidas mira esperate
una cosa que voy a poner esta línea en azul oscuro que va a ser todo mucho más sencillo de seguir
de seguir para vosotros en el caso que acierte la salida de esta también entonces yo las otras
ya veréis que son como rosas y no acuerdo de color más había puesto estas son las originales del
sistema salidas originales del sistema entonces yo ahora que activo las salidas vamos a empezar
por el uno poco a poco por partes y ahora yo le he puesto uno que no me acuerdo cuál es bueno
si lo tengo aquí me acuerdo por eso tengo una chica una chuleta aquí porque no es con 32 la
memoria que tengo pues la primera salida monetaria hemos empezado por lo por lo más sencillo aunque
no están si que las primeras están más o menos ordenadas se llega a un punto que ya nos ordenes
desordenado porque nos hemos dejado aquella nos hemos dejado la otra y entonces claro para para
no ir borrando números y tal hubiera sido un caos bastante heavy al final simplemente hemos
añadido debajo no entonces aquí yo le he añadido ahora un esto monetario que por lo que veo no está
saltando demasiado vale y esto ha cambiado porque va a cero no no está saltando el monetario porque
bueno me vuelvo al código para ir explicando si alguien tiene preguntas que pregunte entonces
lo que os decía es el código del código de salidas tiene como os digo de 0 a 32 de 0 a 7
entradas luego lo veremos también me escondo ahora las entradas y en cuanto a las salidas pues
ves tengo aquí el que es uno con un comentario de qué hace que tiene que es que es uno es un
esto como os digo monetario el que es 2 es un esto porcentual vale se entiende poco la
mecánica el caso de 3 es un esto por aterre el 4 es un profit monetario el 5 el 5 es un profit
porcentual y así sucesivamente hasta 32 vale ya los íbamos viendo poco sobre la marcha no vamos
a verlos todos todos ahora el 6 profit por aterre llega a un punto a partir del 11 así que se van
combinando se van combinando vale como veis aquí hay muchísimo código vale ya desarrollado y esto
creo que puede tener bastante utilidad para todos vale todo para el que esté empezando entonces al
final como os digo hay 32 esto tiene la ventaja de en el mismo código yo puedo probar varios yo
está ya estaba antes investigando un poquito con él cada uno de ellos casi todos tienen unos inputs
y por eso si ahora desplegamos aquí veis que aquí hay un montón de inputs que hemos hecho para que
sean más o menos fáciles de seguir pues poniéndole poniéndole delante el c1 c c01 veis c02 se le no
más o menos de 0 3 de 0 4 luego diré estos dos que son de 0 5 de 0 6 de esta manera sabes a qué
que se refieren entonces si yo pongo arriba salida 10 pues sé que los que tengo que ir a tocar son
los 10 que no hay por cierto hay porque salida exit al cierre de cierre del día entonces pero
si pongo 11 por ejemplo pues sé que la 11 tiene a terres tiene dos a terres por lo tanto pues voy
a mi lista y sé que es el trailing a terres con profit sé que es el trailing a terres con profit
claro esto no pensar que es para optimizarlo todo esto sería una locura vale será una locura pero
sí que puedes utilizar alguno de ellos y ir probando o sea ahora pongo el que es 5 y optimizo
que es 5 pero pruebo un poco vale optimizar a nivel instrumental esto esto sobre todo es
fase de desarrollo de evaluación preliminar y demás acuerdos para diseñar para ayudarte a
diseñar el sistema si todavía no tienes claro por dónde ir o para probar rápidamente distintas
versiones voy a probar esta salida voy a probar otra y hay distintas vale entonces ya digo
están las principales voy a explicar quizá un poquito las más extrañas o las que hemos
visto menos vale porque ya ver esto monetario esto porcentual mezclado bric iber todo el mundo
tiene claro creo que es esto no entonces al final un trailing también vale por ejemplo tenemos
tenemos el 5 a poner algunas así un poco más rebuscaditas poco a poco vamos a empezar la 8
vale que es un trailing un trailing que tiene sólo un parámetro que es el número de aterres vale
voy a ponerme la tierra debajo siempre que hay un periodo el periodo lo hemos puesto lo hemos puesto
arriba para 22 toco de momentos no sé por qué por defecto no tiene el histograma entonces veis
aquí tenéis verde y rosas vez esto quiere decir que ha salido por por ese mecanismo de salida de
acuerdo ha salido mediante que hubiera salido casi igual aquí por ejemplo veis muchas veces en este
caso claro ese sistema ya tiene implementadas las salidas que yo podría inhabilitarlas yo podría
inhabilitar las podría decir bueno yo no quiero que salga esto también se podría hacer mediante
código y es habitual hacerlo pero en en en tres station tenemos esta estas pestañitas de aquí donde
pone o no no que esto por ejemplo multichars no está y a veces viene bien porque yo puedo hacer
que la señal de compras al final son las cuatro señales que hay del sistema by cells el short
by to cover vale al final te permite en tanto en el by que son los de abrir como en el cell
short te permite activarlo desactivarlo o dejarla de salida sólo pero también me permite que las
que son sólo de salida como el cell y como el by to cover desactivar las tal maneras que yo ahora
a la vez ratio les activo sus señales primarias y automáticamente sólo podrá salir por las
ya no veréis más que flechas verdes y rosas es todas son rosas y verdes porque no puede salir
de otra manera de acuerdo no puede ser de otra manera esto desconozco si es mejor o mejor porque
no lo he probado si que hemos hecho antes alguna optimización para ver que estuvieran bien hechos
en principio creo puede ser que se nos currará un bag algunas veces habéis detectado alguno claro
que hemos hecho mucho código y podría ser que hubiera un bag pero vaya principio está muy pasado
tengo que debería debería estar bien vale pero yo ahora aquí básicamente a este sencillo sistema
os puedo evaluar evaluar qué datos me da con la salida de atr y sólo una u otra vale introduciendo
introduciendo está introduciendo esta vuelvo a activar sus salidas originales complementarias
a las otras complementarias a las otras y aquí veremos que pues pues pues se empeora es decir
al final la salida en sí del sistema original no está aportando vamos a ver aquí el ratio
se retorna el riesgo vale vamos a vamos a hacer eso vamos a hacer eso porque es más limpio ver
las salidas y así no ver distinto habíamos los colores pero ahora estoy pensando que y viendo que
no empeora desactivamos el sistema original y dejamos todo el rato las que pongamos nosotros
claro en este caso sí que ya no nos valen no nos valen bueno si nos vale porque el sistema puede
hacer reverse es decir puede puede ir al lado contrario si yo le pongo a una que solo es esto
imaginamos ahora que le pongo la uno es dinero dinero salida a uno el dinero le pongo esto
vamos a bajarlo porque si no pues creo que va a costar mucho que sale 5000 dólares cuando gana
no puede salir no tiene salida cuál es su salida sólo la banda contraria la banda contraria entonces
este probablemente es poco eficiente sobre todo en términos de retorno riesgo porque fijaros aquí
el drawdown que sé que sé que se traga volviendo como no tiene otra salida que la contraria en la
banda contraria pues no no puede no puede salir esto probablemente no es tampoco súper eficiente
en datos de retorno riesgo aunque en el retorno aguanta bien es que bollinger bollinger solo a
mi ratio en petróleo va bastante bien tiene un drawdown fuerte como ya os comenté pero a mi
ratio en petróleo va bien en diarios es un sistema que aguanta bien y en una cesta de materias
primas aguanta bastante bien el tipo y además con la suerte que lleva muchísimos años de
funcionamiento que es un sistema que sigue una pauta muy lógica expansión de volatilidad y por
lo tanto os animo a aquellos que tengáis cuentas grandes porque esto tiene que ser con cuentas
grandes a probarlo en una cesta de distintas materias primas pues yo que sé maíz soja petróleo
oro y más ahora que no me salen pero sean de bastantes tendencia carne bueno tienen poca
liquidez algunas pero se pueden explorar perfectamente y ahí explorar la idea básica
con alguna salida incluso buscaría trabajarlos de manera conjuntamente en diario para evitar
un poco la sobre la sobre optimización pero es una es una cesta viable una cesta que tendrá
puntos débiles muchos pero en la parte de tendencia será una buena cesta en la parte
tendencia recuerdo la protesta necesitaremos a mejores estrategias a tendenciales que pueden
ir en sp pueden ir en bonus vale pero la parte de tendencia seguramente tendremos una cartera
que pasará un poco lo que lo que hablábamos antes en el ejemplo ese que ponía alejandro que
tendrá periodos esto es bastante mejorable pero pero para que me entendáis tenga periodos muy
largos muy planos pero que luego tendrá periodos de locura de esto esto pasa pero bueno que este ya
os digo que sólo el del stop es sólo el de esto vale entonces vamos a dejar deshabilitada esta y
así vamos viendo algunas algunas más vale el trailing cómo funcionaba el trailing que me ha ido
un poco como me suele me suele pasar estábamos con la 8 estamos con la 8 pero ya dejamos deshabilitadas
las de las de haber ratio no originales eso lo sale por este nuevo este código nuestro a medida
que le indiquemos cómo vale que hace un trailing bueno un trailing al final recordar que va siguiendo
el precio este es tan simple como los la mayoría de los que habéis visto calculo un periodo de
aterre por un multiplicador el periodo de aterre es más que esto de aquí abajo que es el rango de
las sesiones media le he puesto 22 y no lo he optimizado pero podría saber investigar por él
aquí hay poco margen porque es diario pero si juntamos unos cuantos futuros a lo mejor podemos
investigarlo un poco de todas maneras estaría bien investigarlo hacer un mapa ahora por ejemplo
para que entendáis y simplemente aquí hay un código que es un poco más rebuscado que algunos
que habéis visto porque contempla un poco aquellos casos extraños aquellas casos que
se escapan pero bueno no sé si vale la pena bueno os lo explico un poco os lo explico un poco mira
voy a ponerme el puntero aquí para ir ayudando os vale para que para que aquellos que no sabéis
todavía mucho de programación me vayáis siguiendo vale esto me interesa que lo
entendáis porque esto es buena plata empezamos aquí que procesa si market position es uno si
estamos largos vale si estamos largos esto tt como veis aquí es total trade esta es una
manera muy útil de programación de identificar en qué barra ha cerrado un trade de acuerdo
porque total trades total trades recoge el número de trades cerrados de acuerdo el número de trades
cerrados de tal manera que en el momento en que se cierra un trade aquí que estoy comparando yo
estoy diciendo total trades en la barra actual es distinto de total trades en la barra anterior
recordar que una entre corchetes a cualquier función o palabra reservada mayoritariamente yo
puedo referirme a su valor en la barra anterior ni si la cuenta esto es tan sencillo como hacer
eso tt entre corchetes 1 entonces eso ocurre solo en la barra en que ha habido un cierre de trade
entonces fijaros fijaros que esto recoge un caso curioso cuando se cierra en la misma barra porque
yo ya parto de que estoy largo entendido parto que estoy largo pero además el pregunto vale no estás
largo pero para ahora veremos para qué que es para actualizar la actualizar la variable para
empezar a guardarla es igual ahora pero los explico para qué lo hace pero pero pero ahora
llego yo os digo si estás largo luego le pregunto si además de estar largo si además de estar largo
o bien el número de trades de esta barra es distinto de la barra anterior esto solo puede
pasar si se ha cerrado un trade pero insisto está es largo para acordar los acuerdos que
estás largo o en la barra anterior market position era distinto de largo es decir era cero cerrado
o corto que es lo normal fijaros que está solo cubre un caso normalmente con esto ya valdría
porque porque yo le digo tú estás largo y en la anterior no estabas largo de acuerdo en la anterior
no estabas largo en ese caso actualiza entonces yo le digo actualiza es decir dale a la variable
pos ha y dar el valor del máximo de la vela para inicializar variables este que caso es en el
caso de que la anterior barra en la anterior barra se hubiera cerrado un largo porque si
en la anterior barra yo estoy largo este no no pasaría este daría false se entiende daría false
por eso es uno u otro en cambio este se quedaría true sería verdadero porque el número de trades
es porque el número de trades ha cambiado y además también le pide que el máximo sea mayor
porque si el máximo no es mayor que el que tiene guardado no tiene sentido actualizar la variable
ya está no no profundizo más pero era simplemente porque este tipo de estructura es bastante usual
en easy language para para actualizar y es porque ya como os pasa en el código pues os la podéis
os la podéis guardar y porque recoge algún caso un poco atípico recuerdo recoge un caso por eso
hay tres si total trades es distinto de total trades anterior si market position en la barra
anterior era distinto de largo o si el hike era mayor que en cualquiera de esos tres casos actualiza
en este caso actualiza porque tiene que actualizar siempre que hace un máximo vale tiene que
inicializarla en este caso porque insisto estas largo vale insisto que todo esto pasa solo si
estás largo por lo tanto si estás largo me interesa eso me interesa actualizar si hace máximos pero
además si eso no pasa y pasa cualquiera de los dos casos también debo hacerlo porque lo que estoy
identificando es que acabo de iniciar una posición entendéis con esto identifico que hago máximos con
esto trato de identificar que acabo de abrir que es la primera barra de acuerdo sea lo que identifico
con estas códigos es la primera la primera barra vale para que se me entienda esta barra la
primera y ahí a partir de ahí es donde me interesa a mí actualizar vale y a partir de ello calculo
entre el incontable que se va actualizando como os digo a medida que yo hago máximos cada vez que
hago un máximo que hay que es mayor que pos hay pos hay vale hay y automáticamente yo a esa cantidad
le resto el atr veremos cuando cae cuando veamos el chandelier que es relativamente relativamente
similar a ver es que el chandelier es relativamente similar ese es un poco el trailing clásico bueno
le llamamos trailing pero es que el chandelier al final es muy similar muy similar lo lo comenté
exclusivamente la ponencia de reboteo y por eso os lo os lo quería enseñar os lo enseño un momento
ahora por ya que he hablado del chandelier lo que hace es desde una banda que en este caso no
actualiza también desde un máximo n vale le resta el atr vale la particularidad o la única diferencia
que tiene es esa el chandelier no está condicionado su autor en su momento no lo condicionó así estás
largo no estás largo a cuando has entrado cuando has entrado es decir es una banda que está siempre
en cambio un trailing empieza a calcularse cuando tú abres por eso hay todas esas ese
ese número de ese código que pretende actualizar la variable de acuerdo pretende recoger pretende
recoger espérate que eso es otra cosa pretende recoger los máximos desde el momento en que
abras de acuerdo es decir insisto en que para que se entienda bien que veo que hay alguna pregunta
y vuelvo aquí al trailing número 8 vale número 8 donde insisto es para que para que entendáis un
poco la jugada voy a tratar a ver si consigo si yo creo que se va se va a ver bien las dos las dos
cosas yo creo que se van a ver bien las dos cosas para que entendáis bien la lógica ya digo no
quiero pararme mucho porque al final el curso no es de programación y hasta ahora he conseguido
no pararme mucho la programación para que veáis que no es importante pero sí que es verdad que a
medida que vamos avanzando pues también quiero daros algunas algunas cositas algunos tips a este
a este nivel de acuerdo una cosa es que para empezar no haga falta y otra cosa es que al
acabar no haga falta es distinto al acabar sí que debemos de tener nociones y entender un
poquito estos estos conceptos y lógicamente a partir de ahí pues evolucionar más entonces lo
que os digo empezamos aquí si margen position igual a igual a uno eso sólo es true en este
trade vamos a vamos a evaluar este entender este trade vale este vale eso sólo estuvo en esta barra
al cierre de esta barra aquí no aquí es false y no entra de acuerdo ahí no entra y aquí es que
aquí se va aquí ya tira tira un stop que eso es un esto que está preparado para lanzarse la para
que la vela de entrada haya esto puesto vale pero el true el primer true de esta sentencia es en esta
vela de acuerdo entonces además ahí es lo que os digo para iniciar la variable ahí no habría
problema porque como veis el máximo a ver esto que creo que está otra vez oscurecido lo voy a
quitar que nos va a ir mucho mejor en esa vela donde se compra fijaros que el máximo es mayor
que la vela anterior con lo cual no hay problema ahí se hubiera actualizado sin esto también el
problema si no hubiera hecho máximos de acuerdo a mí me interesa igualmente actualizarla porque
es la vela en la que yo entro y a mí me interesa en este tipo de esto calcularlo desde que entro no
me interesa de antes como hace chandelier aquí repito ha hecho máximos y por lo tanto no no hay
problema pero hay que contemplar todos los casos si no hubiera hecho máximos vale en la anterior
cómo daría cómo esto sería true para actualizar porque tiene que ser true en esa primera vez la
vale pues podría ser por esta porque me dice en la vela anterior market position era distinto
de 1 es verdad en la vela anterior market position era cero por lo tanto no hay problema no hay
problema no no ahí actualizaría vale pero si en la vela anterior hubiera estado largo vale y cómo
puede ser que porque podría haber estado largo de acuerdo ya de otra vela vale y el hike no
no ser mayor podría haber estado podría haber estado largo y cerrar vale no pero en ese caso
no no sería no sería no sería vale podría haber estado tiene que ser distinto de largo vale bueno
esa si él si es en la vela de entrada va a ser va a ser true en las siguientes va a ser false de acuerdo
en las siguientes va a ser false este este cubre el caso en que cierre y entre la misma vela
básicamente y este cubre el caso o sea esto es cuando total trade es distinto de total trade
anterior que eso solo cambia es decir en todo en toda la vida del trade no ocurre solo solo ocurre
en la última vela en esta vela en esta vela en esta vela total trade es distinto al valor de
anterior entonces digamos que esto trata de cubrir la actualización en la última vela y esto cubre
en la primera vela y esto cubre la actualización normal y corriente que es cuando haga máximo si no
hace máximos no tienes que actualizar se queda guardado con el máximo vale pero estas dos pretenden
que se actualice igualmente si no hace máximos en esas velas vale porque porque es la vela de
me interesa estar seguro que ahí lo identifico si no podría en esos son casuísticas muy muy
especiales si yo eso lo anulo veréis que normalmente hay muy pocas actuaciones hay
muy pocos casos donde se se da que actúe vale pero de esa manera está contemplado todos los
casos y ya dejó el tema entonces ya está el trailing al final simplemente va actualizando a
medida que el precio sube para que lo entendáis porque tengo aquí el chandelier puesto lo voy a
poner lo voy a activar que no es exactamente ese porque actualiza todo el rato pero ese es el
cálculo del chandelier vale que al final para largos y para cortos de acuerdo el azul me va
poniendo el stop de los largos el rojo me va poniendo el stop de los cortos así es un poco
raro de ver pero puedo ocultar una de ellas un momento para que así no no no a lo mejor es
más fácil de entender vale ese es el stop de los largos porque porque le resto al máximo de la
tierra no olvidéis que al final le resto al máximo de la tierra le resto al máximo la tierra es de
del máximo menos la tierra por eso va siguiendo al precio de acuerdo esto esta línea azul que
veis es un típico trailing por aterra vale es un típico trailing por aterra que es el que
recogemos en el número 8 sólo es el 8 que no va mal no va mal por cierto vale y se adapta a la
volatilidad de acuerdo decir esto si tú lo miras en todo el histórico al final se va adaptando a
la volatilidad es algo bastante bastante intuitivo el solo histórico como veis está hecho polvo
pero es igual nos da igual ahora siempre va siguiendo al precio por debajo llega un punto
que deja de tener sentido el sentido porque al final recoge el máximo de unas barras atrás
en este caso pues debe estar en 22 y le resta una cantidad entonces llega un punto que no tiene
sentido cuando ya lo cruza debería de dejarse pintar y hecho eso se puede hacer por código
pero no lo hemos hecho esto deberíamos de en este momento cuando lo perfora dejar de pintarlo
para hacerlo bien hecho por código se puede se puede hacer eso solo pintarlo cuando sea
superior cuando sea cuando su valor sea inferior a al mínimo de acuerdo al mínimo y el del corto
pues lo mismo pero al revés de acuerdo si queréis oscurezco un momento este para que lo veáis más
más claro ahí ahí tenéis un poco la contraria ves que aquí sólo tendría sentido pintarlo
cuando el precio el máximo esté por debajo de acuerdo en el momento que el máximo ya esté
por encima de esa línea pues no la deberíamos de pintar porque es absurda vamos a la derecha que
es el gráfico un poco más más decente vale y ahí está ese tema marcando un poco las líneas donde
salta el stop vale el stop de los cortos en esta casa que sí que la vamos a poner un poquito
transparente no porque así cuando lo pongamos no molesta tanto ahí está ahora la voy a la voy a
ocultar todo caso bien y esté como os digo pues es el stop el salida trailing que es un
stop tipo trailing solo tenía esta esta era la número la número 8 en la 11 además hemos
incorporado que además puede cerrar por tp que no tendencia al puro esto necesito quería aclararlo
porque también me ha llegado un comentario es decir cuando digo que un tenencial puro no quiere
no tiene que tener tp no quiero decir que no haya que ponerle tp a los tendenciales de acuerdo
si lo si quieres que sea puro yo recomiendo no ponerlo pero también puede ser tendencial con tp
explicó y si tienes nuevamente lo que decía antes de la cartera de las materias primas pues a lo
mejor estaría bien mezclar alguno con que lo tenga otro que no lo tenga de acuerdo esa también es
una diversificación muy útil en este caso de acuerdo un sistema lo usaría con un trailing
otro con él con tp porque porque al final contra más tendenciales más pasa este efecto que decía
aquí alejando en el ejemplo vale más pasa vale más pasa esto contra más tendencial más pasa esto
de acuerdo es decir entonces al final claro todo tiene lo bueno y todo tiene lo mal entonces si yo
quiero tener varios pues a lo mejor en uno lo hago tendencial puro pero luego otros algo tendencial
no tan puros de acuerdo no tan puros porque porque los voy estabilizando contra más el tp ya os lo
comentado estabiliza mucho los sistemas es decir ese sistema sólo con tp mira ya veréis vamos a
poner por probarlo que no me acuerdo como iba profit porcentual la profit por atf tengo profit
por atr a ver donde lo tengo profit por atr no tengo profit por atr tengo stop y profit por
atr pero profit por atr solo no lo tengo no lo veo profit por atr número 6 era para ver si estabas
atento alberto pero para ver si estabas atento profit periodo salida no pongo 22 a todo y
número 6 número 6 número 6 número 6 número aterriz vale mira vamos a optimizar
aumentido por curiosidad es igual es por jugar yo que sé esto que es profit a atr y le ponemos de
0 25 a 25 no pero si tan terrible va a ser muy alto no yo que sé de 5 a 15 o que de 0 50 o algo
eso es un momento para jugar para ver un poco alguna pregunta por ahí no todo bien no ya está
para sí sí exactamente a la estrategia como bien te ha contestado alberto total trade es un es una
palabra reservada que cuenta el número de trates recordar los que tengan esos y lengües el
fenomenal uso de queda el diccionario que yo os recomiendo siempre tenerlo aquí a la derechita
le pones aquí ese lengües le pones aquí total trades si lo pones junto te dará total trades y ya
tienes ahí la explicación number of all closed out trades in the life of a strategy un ejemplito y
además te sale el botoncito para abrir la ayuda y obtener más ayuda en este caso no hay mucho que
ayudar porque es lo que es el número de trates es extremadamente útil y recomiendo siempre
cualquier palabra reservada cosa que no veáis darle eso porque es la manera de aprender de verdad
todas a todas las palabras que salen aquí todas las funciones todas las podéis buscar aquí y las
podéis buscar la ayuda el haber hecho también está todas no hay mejor manera de aprender de verdad
es ahora lo hemos dado aquí al optimizador y lógicamente es un punto sobre optimización
probablemente pero bueno que nos da igual que es para jugar un poco con el tema y ahí vemos que
hemos conseguido un sistema super top hemos mejorado muchísimo lo que había y este es de
los seguramente los mejores que los mejores que hay porque porque al final es un tendencial no
le dejo salir con la media ahora no os olvidéis vale y por lo tanto pues bueno le deja a ctp muchas
veces muy muy arriba bueno el 5 de hecho no es que sale o que seguramente aquí tiene
drag down más elevado y de mejor alguno este todos va a tener drag downs muy fuertes porque
no le hemos dejado quitar el drag down de ninguna manera entendéis ya no le hemos dejado más que
ganar dinero entonces gana mucho dinero pero debe tener unos drag downs bastante bestias
seguramente es de los que más gana este serio pero también es de los que más drag down tiene
el seguro vale porque porque no puede salir más que girándose vale no puede ser más que girándose
entonces debe tener alguna enganchada tiene tener muy buenos pero una enganchada como estas bastante
maca y tendrá peores era una enganchada espectacular porque porque no se va a poder cerrar hasta que
hasta que tenga una señal contraria bueno no le he dejado salir de ninguna manera vale pero
claro así cuando pilla tendencia que ya sabéis que las materias miramos el oro ahora la que lleva
su vida luego lo podemos probar también en el oro diario y seguramente nos va a ir bien también
luego lo probamos y porque sólo le dejamos el por profit entonces yo esto puedo usarlo en un
tendencial que es esto si no pasa nada pero veréis que sus ratios de acierto siendo inferior a 50
casi con total seguridad no ya es por encima de 50 pensaba que aún así aguantaría bueno porque
al final le ha quedado un valor relativamente bajo si le hubiera puesto más alto es decir si en vez
de 5 en vez de 5 pues yo que sé le hubiera puesto otro vale otro que equilibre mejor en alguna otra
cosa que no sé si lo va a ver no creo que lo haya al final ninguno ninguno equilibra mejor en
nada ninguno creerá mejor en nada vale que sería ese claramente pero es igual que lo hubiera puesto
11 vale imagina que lo hubiera puesto 11 por allá lo veis aquí aquí creo que sale el
porcentaje de aciertos no sale aquí no sabe bueno se puede ser aquí 57 no todos son muy altos todos
son muy altos todos son muy altos la verdad que me sorprende esperaba que tuviera tuviera más menos
porcentaje de aciertos a ponerle tp pero fijaos ya lo deja lo convierte en bueno lo convierte sigue
siendo tendencial pero ya su carácter es menos tendencial no porque ya no acierta tanto porque
su proteje de acierto ya es muy elevado también en este caso casi con total seguridad es un poco
fruto de sobre optimización fruto de sobre optimización que eso también es señal sospechosa de
un sistema de ratios que no esperas pero bueno para que veáis el ejemplo que os decía venga
seguimos con alguna otra salida un poco más distinta bueno esta es la que os decía antes tenía
sólo la 11 teníamos la 11 que combinaba las dos esa tenía tr y tal es igual dejó el que el que
ya tenía esa tiene trelin además tp es bueno va a hacer tp es en algunos momentos pero se protege
mediante el trelin que lo va lo mantiene pegadito ahí lo mantiene pegadito ahí todos estos ya digo
en general todos que aseguro que ganan bien ganan bien porque son salidas que va muy bien al tendencial
lo deja correr fijaos este al final lo ha dejado más más acompañado porque porque sale por tp y
además tiene un nivel que lo protege lo protege de las vueltas entonces este ya no tiene enganchadas
ya no tiene enganchadas prácticamente ya la cosa mejora vamos a tratar de verlo así a ver si se
ve se ve todo bien porque si ya no tiene enganchadas vale este es trelin con profit
ese está bastante bien como como porque al final cuando uno habla de stop y tp al uso vale que
es el mira os lo voy a poner ahora un momentito para que lo veáis entender en cuenta que son
stops que van mejor en los anti tendenciales vale yo no tendencial necesito acompañar al precio
porque si yo quiero que corra mucho que sentido tiene que el esto lo ponga en la entrada final
un esto sea monetario o sea porcentual mira tengo el porcentual y monetario a ver esto porcentual
y profit porcentual número 16 vale lo tengo en el 16 ahora os enseño lo tengo en el 16 entonces
yo no 16 con stop y un profit porcentuales solo puedo salir por eso vale entonces y por el giro
claro es que pasa pues es muy errático porque al final no le estoy dejando al sistema salir
de ninguna manera si aquí yo a ver cómo los he puesto es el número 16 4 y 2 el doble vale si yo
aquí le dejo esto p este 4 y esto le pongo 1 o que esto es multiplicador ahora voy al código ahora
voy al código ahora lo he dejado stop y tp simétrico tengo una entrada este con una entrada que es
tendencial pero le he obligado a que tenga una salida anti tendencial aún así me da ratios
a no me da ratios ya más por encima de 50 veces el otro era a un tendencial ahora lo he vuelto
a tendencial aún así me da 52 que me está diciendo que alguna ventaja tiene pero es muy
justita muy justita vale puesto así pero ahí estoy poniendo stop y tp simétrico acordaros que
esto os lo dije que es una manera de evaluar a veces ventajas pero sobre todo en el caso
anti tendencial también puede servir aquí para evaluar un poco la entrada vale porque yo me estoy
saliendo de manera simétrica pero esto para que se entienda quiere decir que yo cuando el precio
sube el precio cae un porcentaje que nos hiciera un 4 vale cuando era ver 4 65 como 5 de ar vale
cuando tiene un esto de un 5% y un tp de un 5% según uno lo que hace es el multiplicador del mismo
5 y 5 no es claro al final es justito si así es muy justito porque esa es una salida más apta
para tendencial que ha sido premiso mejorará si mejorará claro que mejorará pero como yo ahora
le he quitado la salida así dejándole su salida de media tendría cierto sentido vale pero está
está quitándole esa salida tiene muy poco sentido entendéis esto es lo que hablaba en la ponencia
de robot y yo os dije que la escenería aquí hoy era esto era reflexionar y entender no la
que ya he hablado de sentido común que a veces es fruto muchas veces la experiencia de buscar
las las cosas que tienen sentido para cada tipo de entrada entonces entonces y yo al final busco
tendencia no tiene sentido poner un stop y un tp al uso a no ser que tenga la otra salida si
yo activo la salida entonces ya mejoró mucho porque porque automáticamente le he dado una salida
contraria relativamente cercana y ahora le he dejado ahora para que se entienda yo le he dicho
vamos a suponer que el precio de entrada el precio de entrada es esta línea vale pues yo
le he dicho simplemente que a la misma distancia que sería más o menos esto no tenga un stop y
un tp es esto a la misma distancia desde la entrada es igual si sube si sube si sube era tp y si
baja ahora esto esto ya lo dije es muy habitual ir a uno a uno empieza a tener más sentido si yo
como ya estaba puesto doblo el tp del stop digo bueno pues vale en vez de ir vale y por eso los
he configurado así que los enseño el código y os lo recomiendo lo dije ya lo había dicho creo
en el curso pero insisto ahora en ello os recomiendo configurar los stops tp es cuando
os hagáis de esta manera ahora os enseño en el código vale que es yo pongo un stop en
este caso por ciento igual y el profit lo hago múltiplo de este de tal manera que yo digo
este es esta configuración de esta variable está persen del c16 al 5% y c16 profit stop percent 1
quiere decir que está también al 5% porque lo multiplico por 1 entendéis si yo le pongo 2
quiere decir que el profit es un 10% y si yo le pongo 3 quiere decir que el profit es un 15%
entendéis ahora le pongo 2 vale y el profit es 10% ahí por ejemplo seguramente no lo va a hacer
así mira justo justo al máximo justo al máximo ahora le he puesto 10% ahora ya se vuelve más
tendencial y ha mejorado un poco porque porque es un activo que quiere tendencia porque tiene
muchas muy colas largas entonces las colas largas tienen que pagar los fallos tienen que hacer
estos grandes tricks para pagar los fallos es mejor algo sigue siendo peor pero ves ya ha caído
el 50 por ciento de haciernos y es un típico tendencial así tengo que hacerlo así sí puedo
hacerlo pero aún así seguramente no es eficiente porque porque mira aquí tenés el ejemplo porque
desde el precio de entrada el calcula esa es lineal como os decía de acuerdo es decir yo que
aquí tal y tp bueno perdón era el 15 y el estado faltó y ya está y le da igual en lo que haga el
precio vale esa es la diferencia con un trailing un trailing es un poco como la media la media va
subiendo por eso es lo que os decía si yo activo la media va a mejorar porque porque la media al
final me está haciendo de trailing entendéis me está haciendo de trailing entonces si yo quiero
usar ese tipo de stops mejor que deje activará del sistema que probablemente mejore bueno ahora
habrá que ver si el tp queda demasiado lejos y tal pero es sólo con eso ya mejorado pues ya mejorado
porque porque cuando vuelve veis aquí qué pasa este que ha vuelto pero la media lo saca la media
le hace de trailing vale pues claro en un tendencial no tiene sentido que yo vaya stop y profit si no
tengo otra salida insisto pues ahora vuelvo a desactivar la media porque así entendemos bien
las salidas vale vamos en bruto en este ejercicio hoy de completo de salidas que al final como
sabéis y se dice es muy muy importante y marca mucho el carácter y el perfil de un sistema porque
al final es lo que ejecuta la ganancia la pérdida aunque todo es importante lógicamente la ventaja
lo da la entrada la salida es lo que acaba de materializar el vale entonces esto cuando lo
os decía de enseñaros en el código esto de 16 no creo que era no el 6 16 6 es 16 yo tengo
los inputs y simplemente le digo si marca el posición es distinto de cero vale es distinto
de cero lanza un set stop loss porque esto tengo una palabra entre sesión que me lo calcula y me
ayuda mucho si no pues puedo calcular la manija de acuerdo puedo calcularlo vale pero esto tres
sesiones tiene una palabra reservada que es esto que no lo sé diccionario diccionario es que no
sé si lo pregunto a ser si no no se lo pregunto a ser si lo busco aquí lo busco aquí lo leo y
entonces si después de leerlo y tal no lo entiendo le preguntas a lo primero lo busco porque de verdad
la manera sea lo que hablaba varias clases de la teoría el carácter de cuantitativo y
agonímico exige esto exige esta inquietud sino os va a costar mucho exige esta inquietud de la
de la búsqueda de la análisis de entender las cosas vale no ir a lo fácil simplemente de acuerdo
hay que entender hay que tener las cosas y buscarlas y ya digo la una de las cosas buenas que tiene
es su fantástica ayuda de verdad que es de las mejores que está todo normalmente muy bien
explicado aquí es lo que digo es un built-in stock reservoir son los que tenéis el curso
visit language que sois la mayoría pues ya está está ahí explicado y lo explico más detalle pero
que también la ayuda viene viene bien al final tú puedes sacar ahí un valor monetario directamente
al uso 500 mil o un cálculo que es lo que hacemos aquí un cálculo esto al final acaba siendo
dinero pero cómo se calcula se múltiple se calcula multiplicando el precio de entrada por
un porcentaje que está en tanto por cien un 2% un 3% lo divido por cien porque porque para
para multiplicarlo por el precio de entrada y lo multiplico por pinpoint value que es lo que
convierte puntos en dinero es lo que convierte puntos en dinero y ya está ya con eso ya me tira
de esto para el precio que quiero y el set profit target es igual pero veis que además
multiplico el esto percent lo multiplico por esa variable que os decía que es múltiplo de él si
esa variable vale 1 pues son iguales si esa variable vale 2 pues el doble no vaya vale ese
número que da se divide por cien se multiplica y lo mismo vale y ya está y esto que veis aquí
detrás del else es porque aunque set stop loss se usa lo explico porque puede generar confusión
porque aquellos que no tengáis mucha experiencia digáis coño pero si es que set stop loss es el
profit target a mí me has dicho en el curso easy language que es un stop que va en la barra de
entrada y te digo tienes razón es cierto va en la barra de entrada vale y medio ciento es porque
me pones este bucle de si es distinto de cero y luego me pones que cuando no es decir cuando es
cero vale esta parte de aquí se calcula solo cuando está cerrado que sentido tiene calcularlo
cuando está cerrado el sentido es que cuando entra tener en cuenta cómo se procesa el código muy
breve porque eso no es cuando yo abro esta posición hasta que no cierre la barra no se
leerá market position igual a 1 vale por lo tanto las órdenes que se tienen en esa barra
se han calculado en la anterior vale es decir todo lo que se tira en la barra que estamos comprados
se ha calculado en esta vale por lo tanto el stop no se ha calculado porque esta barra era 0
market position en esta barra era cero no era 1 cuando está cierre la que está larga donde
estaba y cuando está cierre market position será 1 pero el anterior era cero market position por
lo tanto no hay stop en esa barra en teoría como hay esto con esa barra con esto hay perdón
gracias a esto hay esto en esa barra y tú que eres un alumno avanzado y que te has estudiado
muy bien y si luego es podías decirme joder y vaya vaya a imitar esas alturas porque no lo
sacas de market position y se acaba el problema no pues no lo pongas por lo directamente abajo
del código que muchos códigos lo hacemos así lo habéis visto sólo por una cosa si tienes que
usar entre price vale si tienes que usar entre price tienes que hacer esto porque entre price en
esa barra te va a dar cero y entonces se te va a romper se te va a romper no te va no te va a
calcular bien y esto si quieres lo demuestro un momentito haciendo así haciendo así haciendo así
haciendo así y haciendo así para que haciendo así también claro dejando sólo el esto normal
vale dices así lo normalmente siguen a usar entre price podría dejarlo así vale sin market
position pero ahora y ahora voy a compilar esto voy a tratar de abrir aquí el gráfico lo máximo
posible que se me vean algunas varias operaciones y voy a compilar mira mira miremos también el
resultado que tenemos 1 18 ahora ha ido bien matame porque ahora decía yo digo no más matame
le estaba viendo alberto ya que me mataron en directo eso ya sería la buena veis se ha roto ya
no está haciendo lo que tiene que hacer vale no está haciendo lo que tiene que hacer por qué
porque entre price muchas balas velas no calcula bien de acuerdo entre peso calcula si esto fuera
cierre entonces sí pero claro entonces no lo calcularía del precio de trabas y lo quiero
calcular realmente sobre el precio de entrada tengo que hacer esta terquiñola vale vuelvo atrás
vuelvo atrás vuelvo atrás si aquí yo pusiera 10.000 directamente no hace falta de hecho por
ejemplo aquí es así punto 7 sobre los da igual si está largo se está corto si está pensionista
si lo que sea no importa en ese caso es porque yo quiero usar la barra calcularlo de entre price
se entiende verdad venga seguimos entonces hemos visto el porcentual tú me controlas las preguntas
alberto si va relacionado con esto paro porque es importante vale no no pues no contestas tú o sea
si no me relaciona con esto contestas tú o lo dejamos para el final venga entonces bien hemos
visto antes por encima chandelier bueno por encima y no tanto por encima es decir chandelier al final
no deja de ser un trailing vale lo tenemos combinado hemos hecho un chandelier solo
hemos hecho un chandelier con salida temporal vale hemos hecho varias varias opciones vale varias
opciones aquí una de las cosas que sí puedes hacer lo que pasa que claro hay que tener en cuenta
que yo ahora antes sí que lo he dimensionado ahora creo que he tocado alguno me lo habré
medio cargado a esperarle que no ha compilado esa hora no ha compilado eso otra vez entonces
una de las cosas que sí puedes hacer pero claro tienen que tener sentido las variables es colocarlo
sí que puedes hacer una pequeña búsqueda así rápida en las salidas vamos a ver de 0 a 32 como
va vale pero insisto si lo le has dado a los inputs un cierto sentido es complicado tiene que
tener cierto sentido pero sí que puedes por ejemplo igualar todos los estos porcentuales
voluntarios siempre los tres listados a hacer un pequeño voltaje previo dedicarle 15 minutos
a dejarlos todos iguales vale proporcionales en un tendencial pues ya eso que te digo le pongo el
profit el doble que el stop sabes entonces estas cosas coherentes que decíamos y al trailing pues
le dejo oscilar en dos aterres a todos los a que uso aterre pues uso dos aterres uso el mismo
periodo es decir todos de manera homogénea vale y entonces paso la búsqueda directa de todos y así
veo por dónde va por dónde van los tiros de acuerdo quiere decir que directamente con eso
me quede pero ahora yo puedo mirar vale automáticamente que la optimización cuáles
han dado mejor valor aquí veo que el número 18 el número 11 vale el número 18 pues es el
chandelier con profit porcentual o sorpresa 11 es trailing aterre con profit aterre o sorpresa
el número 24 es profit porcentual con brick y bien a bueno pues este era este es muy interesante
este lo vamos a trabajar ahora porque antes decía el profit porcentual claro porque porque cubre la
salida tienes cubre la salida que os decía antes el profit porcentual que problema tiene que no
tiene ningún trailing claro el brick y bien le hace trailing y le llega a compensar él dice oye a
mí hazme tp y cuando falle con que me cierre cuando vuelva con que me cierre esa precio de entrada
ya ya me vale este es un poco el 24 el 24 es ese 24 hace exactamente eso es saber ahora tiene un
tp que no sé cuánto está puesto ahora lo miro es tiene un tp que muchas veces se ejecuta lógicamente
ha cuidado porque esto está rojo a me ha dejado la salida por media espérate no la he quitado
sería por media y porque me salen rojo a bueno porque haces top and reverse claro claro perdón
perdón porque haces top and reverse porque va a la banda contraria vale vale va a la banda contraria
cuando acumula cierto beneficio claro también cuánto beneficio le he puesto a el brick y bien
ese también es un tema un tema importante pero bien vamos a hacer un poco este ejercicio que os
decía de dejarlos pues más o menos coherentes tenemos yo que sé tenemos aquí esto en 5.000 no
pero este cuanto era antes no era 5.000 el código creo estaba el stock monetario en 8.000 creo que
era 8.500 vale 8.500 es el jugado antes son 1500 esto el porcentual sí que lo dejaba entre 75
pues mira vamos a dejar el monetario en 5.000 el stock porcentual en 375 siempre que hagan estos
vamos a usar esos el número de aterres tengo aquí uno extraña que fuera uno era uno pues de cada
dejamos uno dejamos siempre caer aterre 1 1 es sólo aterre solo y luego os lo explico vale no lo he
tocado aquí tengo profit dólares me sale 11.000 pero mi porcentaje 6.25 vale perfecto pues ya
tenemos las dos 11.000 y 6.25 es que casi dobla casi más que doblar pero otra vez fijado no no
llega a doblar no llega a doblar 8.500 11.000 vale 6.25 número de aterres como que número aterres
11 esto que hace el 6 porque es tan grande esto alberto 12 a profit periodo de salida a bueno
porque ese es el número de aterres que sale claro cambia mucho con el de arriba de 6 11 a ver a veces
era 2 ya me extrañaba a mí le voy a dejar un otro todo todo lo que es aterre le pongo a uno bricky
ven 5.250 ese me interesa dejar 5.000 porque donde haría esta venga 5.000 aterres te pongo
uno número de barras mira 17 pues voy a poner 15 venga voy a redondear un poquito todo 8 4 4 10
10 es nuestro juega profit 11.000 esto lo dejamos en 6 1 5.000 de bricky ven 5.000 de bricky ven
una tr número de barras 15 venga 15 venga aquí aterre 1 aterre 2 claro que ese es el profit el
11 lleva profit y demás no trae liga t r y profit a t r vale profit a t r sí que tiene sentido doblar
el otro vale no vamos a dejar este en 4 y éstos me equivoco estoy aquí no sé trabajo aquí dejamos
4 y 2 12 1 no sé cómo quedará desviación banda 2 2 estos son bolinges pensé en traer venga 9
vale ese es el esto lo dejamos igual que antes 8.500 profit por esto este hemos dicho que era
casi el doble no llegaba no 1 1 y medio venga esto porcentual esto era antes un 4 4 profit
esto hemos dicho que 1 y medio a t r es uno veces de esto sobre a t r pues 1 y medio hemos
dicho a t r es 1 profit per cent esto era 6 25 creo 25 esto no esto era 4 número de barras hemos
puesto 15 a t r es uno barras 15 desviación desviación número de barras 15 desviación
desviación número a no esto va a tomar es el parabólic no lo tocamos va por defecto luego
os hablo del parabólic porcentaje 6 6 ya está bien bricky ven 5.000 esto porcentual 4 bricky ven
5.000 profit porcentual 6 no bricky ven porcentual esto no sé cuánto era pero bueno por relación
debe ser un 8.500 es un 3 no 3 por ahí demasiado 2 y medio 2 y medio esto porcentual 4 bricky ven
porcentual este que hemos hecho ahora no cuando era 4 no 2 y medio porque el porcentual otra vez
esto porcentual 4 profit porcentual 6 bricky ven porcentual 4 es los va igualando todo lo que
puede haber alguno que me habré equivocado esto era 8.500 no esto dólares profit de los 11.000 y
ya voy acabando bricky ven dólares 5.000 número a t r es 1 profit por a t r hemos dicho que 1 y medio
y bricky ven porcentual 2 y 2 y medio pues ya está y ahora sí que vuelvo a utilizar esto
tenéis un poco la cuadra entonces yo tengo valores entre todos lo más homogéneos posibles y evalúo
sin tener que optimizar todos es decir a lo mejor miro 1 miro esto miro tal y lo saco un poco de
manera análoga al resto no seguramente donde está más el lío porque había algún a t r que era de
trelling italia y creo que la he liado un poco los aterres pero todo lo demás no bricky ven tal tal
todo esto le ponemos el mismo a todos y con eso ya tienes que ver cuál sale más o menos mejor que
ya lo habíamos visto más o menos serán serán parecidos serán parecidos y con esto ponemos un
poquito un estudio de por dónde respira cada estrategia vale ahora vamos a hacer una pausita
de dos minutos que tengo que ir aquí a visitar a un amigo aquí el pasillo al final entonces ahora
ya veo un poquito pues con lo que he tocado pues claro es que ahora me sale 3 y 24 me sale
esto para t r cuidado esto para t r ahora me sale me sale muy bien 24 que ya creo que salía antes
que era el profit porcentual con bricky ven el 9 el 9 temporal eso me sorprende eso me sorprende
el 2 esto porcentual y 28 bueno ha cambiado un poquito ha cambiado un poquito pero bueno
ésta era un poco la idea para echar un vistazo rápido de por dónde va la cosa por dónde va
la por dónde van los factores luego podemos analizar cada uno de cada uno de ellos en más
profundidad lógicamente vale entonces qué más qué más esto tenía bueno chandelier ya os lo he
explicado bueno chandelier tiene una particularidad que no hemos usado hay dos cosas que no os he
explicado vale que os aprovecho para explicaros la ahora mira una es esto del suelo y techo que
habéis visto vale esto es un poco porque a nosotros nos gusta lo hemos dejado sin configuración
cuando veamos la gestión monetaria ya os dije que os explicaría nuestro ratio de gestión monetaria
principal y viene muy relacionado con esto vale al final aquí tenemos un valor de atr que al final
se calcula simplemente ya sea un profit ya sea un stop ya sea lo que sea un multiplicador por el
atr de acuerdo y esto os comenté cuando hablaba por ejemplo también el robot y el curso lo hemos
comentado que es una manera al final de normalizar final esto es un porcentaje vale porque porque el
atr como al final va calculándose por el precio al yo al añadirle un multiplicador multiplicador
que es constante en todo el histórico me estoy adaptando a los precios de acuerdo no estoy usando
un valor de stop constante 5000 6000 estoy usando un multiplicador de el precio vale
añadiendo un multiplicador que es lo mismo que un porcentaje de acuerdo entonces al final
qué problema tiene el atr vale el problema que tiene la tierra visualmente ya se nota es que si
yo añado un es vamos a suponer que sea un esto vale que sea un esto que multiplique este valor
del atr bueno pues pues no sé por por dos vale quiere decir que cuando yo estoy por ejemplo aquí
vale estoy multiplicando voy a tratar de hacer la machada de escribir en pantalla cuidado vamos
a suponer es nueve más o menos no vale es nueve es nueve imaginamos que lo multiplico por esto
por tres atr vale y lo multiplicó por big point value que es mil vale ahí tengo el temporizador
lo quito el valor de la tierra por tres elemento el 3 es igual 3 2 vale por mil pues esto es 9
por 3 27 27 por mil aquí en japón y en china son 27 mil vale quiere decir que yo a este valor
estoy poniendo un esto de 27 mil vale imaginaros de aquí bueno si no lo hubiera multiplicado por
mil por value vale pues serían 27 de acuerdo aquí vamos a suponer a ese máximo vale ahora yo a ese
máximo espérate que lo estoy perdiendo otra vez esto es aquí le estoy restando en 9 por 3
27 vale 27 estando a 116 vale 28 le resto 27 es decir lo pondría el stop en 89 la línea no
podría tener un color más más malo no hay bueno porque lo tengo nuevamente en negro en 89 28 sería
en este supuesto el esto vale esta línea bien hay gente que puede considerar que eso está demasiado
alejado ahora vamos otra vez a ver a ver ese ese supuesto ahí en ese máximo vale que lo voy a
dejar puesto con un círculo suyo para que no para que quede claro cuáles vale bien ahora vamos a ver
un poco el caso contrario el caso contrario vale sitio donde esté muy baja aunque sea ahora precios
más o menos actuales no ha intentado poner que aquí tras esta vuelta bueno esta zona parece de
muy baja volatilidad vale donde yo me acerco ahí y tengo ahí un nivel de atr de 111 vamos a poner
que es uno vale por por simplificar hacer los reales para que era por aquí creo no si era por
aquí que era 1116 para hacer por hacer fácil venga 1 entonces hacemos igual 1 por 3 es 3 no
falla no falla por esa 27 era 1 por 3 es 3 entonces quiere decir que a este precio de aquí vale a
este nivel de aquí vamos a coger el día que es más bajo vale que es 113 113 este aquí vale este
aquí del máximo en esto es quitarle 3 50 68 menos 3 38 menos 3 vale el esto es 47 68 vale otra vez
47 68 47 68 estamos hablando de este día y entonces hay hay quien puede considerar que
es muy cerca es un poco la jugada no era este era aquí vale que tampoco lo parece tanto esto
habría que verlo he cogido aquí un día lo mejor como este no es relativo para mirar esto realidad
mira voy a hacer porque no me costa nada es mucho mejor mirarlo normalizado vale porque
porque realmente mirar que día hay poca y mucha volatilidad y claro aquí el normalizado se rompe
porque entró negativo no me acordaba le acordaba que entró negativo y entonces se nos rompe así
que es complicado de mirar es complicado de mirar es ver y ver y complicate de mirar alberto
pero bueno hasta aquí sí que es verdad que teníamos valores de 2 no parece ese tan bajo
era más bajo aquí es 2 2 por ciento claro el donde es más bajo es relativo porque de hecho
fijaros esa hora donde está parece muy baja vale porque es lo que digo del valor del punto sube
por lo tanto fijaros ahora que está en el 2 0 3 esa es ahora donde donde sería más claro mirarlo
vale porque ahora es donde parece que esté muy bajo no veo aquí niveles tan bajos en ningún momento
a ver aquí antes de que se rompa 240 si el más bajo es ahora aquí también aquí también si si
donde lo estábamos mirando era bajo era bastante baja era bastante baja era 220 no era tan baja
como ahora pero era baja era baja era baja y aquí al principio es muy baja también vale vale aquí
al principio no es que aquí las velas están rotas vale pero bueno es igual me entendáis el
ejemplo entonces esto aquí no lo no lo usamos siempre y de hecho lo tenemos configurado para
usarlo no y ahora mismo por ejemplo no lo estamos usando pero os lo explico porque lo he puesto ahí
en el código para que lo entendierais vale lo que hace es poner un valor mínimo y máximo entendéis
es decir dejar no permitir que el valor de el valor de la tierra baje demasiado entendéis para
evitar esas picos que a lo mejor son excesivos y por qué que hay detrás de eso no puede decir
hombre pero si es excesivo es excesivo sí pero el mercado sobreactúa digamos sobre reacciona mejor
dicho y entonces hay muchas veces que ese pico de volatilidad automáticamente va seguido de baja
volatilidad de acuerdo entonces realmente a ti te están poniendo un stop súper súper alejado que
está haciendo que sea imposible de que salte y que no acabe de ser realista al movimiento del
mercado vale porque porque el indicador de volatilidad un poquito retrasado y al revés
también pasa un poco lo mismo es decir baja tanto la volatilidad que hace que en el momento que
empieza a dispararse realmente me salta el stop en nada vale me salta demasiado coge un valor
demasiado bajo entonces al final esto que habéis visto aquí en el código lo que hace es limitar
yo le puedo dar un atr suelo y un atr techo si quiero si a esos valores les pongo un valor
muy elevado pues no no hace nada porque al final eso pasa por esta función max list min list repito
que estos códigos los compartiremos y por lo tanto te limita esto lo hacemos igual ya lo adelanto en
la gestión monetaria y ahí es mucho más crítico vale muy breve porque lo explicaremos cuando lo
hagamos pero imaginaros aquí que hace la gestión monetaria porque eso va en el denominador poner
muy pocos lotes eso puede tener sentido vale pero donde tiene menos es el lado contrario es decir yo
ahora tengo muy poca volatilidad y que hago si uso gestión monetaria dependiendo de la atr como el
divisor es muy pequeño me pone muchos contratos y como me pone muchos contratos si ahora viene
una expansión de volatilidad que es algo frecuente acordaros que las expansiones bien
precedidas de contracciones y viceversa automáticamente me coge la hostia con una
exposición muy alta porque como el atr está en el denominador divido por muy poco vale cómo
se soluciona poniendo unas bandas de mínimo y máximo o sólo de mínimo de acuerdo nosotros ahora
mismo trabajamos sólo con mínimo pero lo tenemos configurado para usar los dos es decir que nos
limite el mínimo dejamos que reduzca al máximo sí que actualmente no dejamos que baje de un lote
pero se puede hacer que haga y muchos autores lo hacen y nosotros podríamos hacerlo ahora mismo
no lo hacemos porque con la cartera que tenemos preferimos que tengan exposición todos aunque sea
la mínima pero podría bajarse la exposición hasta el nivel de decir si hay tanta volatilidad yo te
pongo cero vale nosotros no lo hacemos lo dejamos al mínimo pero por a por abajo sí que limitamos
el hecho de poner demasiadas posiciones ya lo veremos cuando cuando lo hagamos vale bien acabo
brevemente la explicación para luego probar en algún otro activo que tras la tras la pausa vale
entonces chandelier es lo que os decía chandelier tiene esta configuración a chandelier tiene otra
cosa aparte esto esto eso que os decía ahora lo tienen los aterres vale esta capacidad de limitar
el suelo y el h siempre que hay una tierra pues le metemos esta capacidad de limitarlo pero es
una capacidad que si tú le das un valor alto tú le das a la tierra un valor de 20 nunca da porque
es en porcentual y le pones cero y ya está no actúa entendéis decir este está estos códigos
a nosotros nos gustan muchos que son lo que llamamos generalización es decir yo le puedo
poner este módulo que simplemente me permite regular las bandas pero si las quiero usar las
uso si no las quiero usar no has usado chandelier es lo que os digo chandelier tiene a no no lo
tiene no tiene al final hemos quitado aquello de si si si si si se acercaba no lo hemos quitado
lo hemos quitado porque hemos pensado que no tenía que no tenía sentido vale vale lo hemos
quitado bueno chandelier es lo que decía son esas bandas que habéis visto todo el rato calculadas y
ya está vale ya está y qué más bueno además también hemos implementado la bólinger banda
contraria que aquí no tiene sentido pero en otro sistema puede tenerla vale que salga en la bólinger
banda contraria algunas otras mezclas el parabólico el parabólico es lo quiero os lo quiero poner para
que lo veáis porque es muy visual es una salida que en algunas estrategias puede ir bien no es
seguramente la más eficiente pero hay gente que le gusta y oye también es importante operar con
cosas que te sientas cómodo y pues la voy a no perdón esto no es salida 23 salida 23 yo os la
voy a poner en pantalla porque ya tengo aquí el indicador para que lo veáis lo veáis parabólic
era el 23 parabólico ahora también se podría haber metido parabólico no más parabólico inventó
wilder y además él lo usaba por se llama parabólico porque es stop and reverse él decía
que era un indicador para girarse es decir no no decía que era sólo para para stop para que lo
tenéis en la ayuda explicado parabólico vale explicado es de wilder wilder era un autor que
le debemos muchas cosas porque fue muy prolífico el atr el movimiento direccional bueno muchas
cosas y bueno él habla de eso tiene dos parámetros y uno de que limita su capacidad uno que es la
aceleración es un trailer que se va acercando vale y el otro que regula la posición inicial podemos
decir de alejado está ahora en sus valores por defecto y entonces cuando el precio toca pues
sale vale es muy rápido como veis vale para un sistema tendencial como este es muy rápido y
le va a evitar las colas largas sin duda eso sí protege mucho de acuerdo protege mucho protege
mucho el beneficio es decir a medida que va acumulando protege mucho pero hay que hay que
verlo cuando se regula de entrada es mejor porque entrante se hubiera entrado aquí tienes aquí
tenemos una entrada que es sólo por por por bollinger por lo tanto es más lenta que parabólico y
salida por parabólico la salida parabólica si es un poco rápida vale porque fijaros la entrada
para que me entendáis lo que digo cuando cambia es que tiene puntitos se ven a los voy a poner
un poquito más gruesos porque me imagino que estando aquí se deben ver se deben ver regular
a ver vamos a poner ahí bien bien gordito y el cross no hace falta y no hace falta nada
entonces al final ves cuando se gira es para los giras de acuerdo es decir aquí está protegiendo
está protegiendo el stop del corto que es que aquí te compra es un poco así entonces aquí
hubiera vendido es donde cierra aquí es donde vende ahí se pone corto aquí se pone largo
y pasiva así un poco aquí no hay posición y no cierra pero cada vez que hay un cambio de color
de viene viene en azul y se pone rojo o morado en este caso va corto cuando se pone azul va largo
tenés base y de hecho en easy language está ya como sistema está como sistema lo puedes meter
decir bueno hay activos que puede ir bien pero ya veis que va como acelerando con el precio se
puede regular ese puede regular y puede tal pero bueno final como todo y esto si le pones 0 3 va
a ser más lento ahora esto la aceleración a no no este es el límite perdón pero el de arriba
de arriba 0 0 3 0 0 3 ahora te lo va te va regulando como como regulada aceleración este regular el
valor máximo que puede tener así en principio hasta que no subamos bastante multiplicado no va
no va a alterarse pero aquí se le va subiendo pues veréis que al final a no al revés así
acelera más al revés por verdad así así es como es más lento es como se aleja más que le
quitas aceleración se acerca menos ahora sí aquí bajar el máximo se notará creo es no se nota
carajo ese es el límite en principio limita el valor que empieza no pues sólo cuando sólo sólo
si lo aceleras mucho se nota entonces para que veas un poco cómo cómo funciona cómo funciona vale
simplemente ya está ese es el parabólic entonces ahí lo mismo pues después salidas aquí en este
caso para un sistema tan tendencial le cuesta le cuesta porque entra demasiado tarde pero bueno
y ahí lo tenéis puesto en el código y como digo hay gente que le gusta mucho el parabólico vale
al final tendenciales como ya os comenté y lo decía que en una diapositiva aquellos que no
hayáis visto de robot raider no ya lo hemos comentado pero la clase pero yo tenía título
de título de consumen no era esto no era esto un tendencial al final o no sale de acuerdo o no
sale se entiende sale por fin de por su señal contrario en ese caso sería la media central un
trailing de acuerdo un trailing es lo que lo que normalmente va a pedir trailing hay el trailing
puro hay chandelier distintas opciones y cambio muy reversión sí que es más más típico que use
que use su es casi obligado su esto su tp el tendencial también la salida por tiempo en todos
aporta acuerdo en todos suele aportar salir por tiempo como complemento vale pero es lo que os
decía tener en cuenta que os quita la capacidad tendencial es decir le quita pureza vale pero
puede añadir puede añadir en algunos en algunos casos y la salida por tiempo es bastante intuitiva
vale porque es lo que lo que os enseñaba lo que lo que os decía porque en al final no
la mejor manera de quitar el riesgo del mercado es estar fuera entonces aquí por ejemplo había
alguno que era a ver algo con mira esto porcentual de tiempo no no tenemos una tr y tiempo alberto
a ver a tr y tiempo tre tre no no lo veo di algo chandelier contemporá tenemos 20 pero ves no está
en trailing con tiempo míratelo trailing normal por ejemplo el trailing de el 8 está el 11 con
trailing con profit y no está trailing con tiempo no está trailing con tiempo púntalo please tengo
el chandelier vale me quedo con el chandelier que es el número 20 es el número 20 voy a pasarle
un momentito una priorización para porque me ha quedado es lo que os decía este le he capado
demasiado el tp este es este es muy bueno me ha quedado el tp muy muy capado es el número 20
número 20 esas optimizaciones son de investigación que de claro esto va a salir alto seguro voy a
poner hasta de 1 a 6 y barras yo creo que va a salir alto esto esto va esto va rápido esto va
si faltaría faltaría este por tiempo de hecho no en base que hay muchos no hay chandelier temporal
esto porcentual temporal por el solo y si nos falta algún temporal hay que hay que meterle
caña a la temporal o sea trailing algún otro tal la mira los temporales que los temporales
complementa bastante bien y falta alguno falta alguno más con temporal alguno más con temporal
si pregunta si puedes añadir que si si tú puedes añadir esto al final yo te doy el código tú
puedes añadir aquí lo que quieras es decir es tuyo uso libre y cualquier que es y reproduces
mezclas uno con otro como ahora he visto pues se nos ha olvidado este por ejemplo tiene entonces
al final es que hay muchas combinaciones al final tú en cada que es de piedras por los simples y luego
compuestos compuestos y el 16 por ejemplo esto porcentual el profit porcentual el 17 esto va a
tener un profit a tf vale el 18 chandelier y profit porcentual entonces así un poquito
poquito y yo recomiendo más porcentual o a tf que valores absolutos pero también están y en muchos
casos pueden dar buenos resultados pero ya os he explicado por qué vale os da buenos resultados
porque salta menos y en algunos casos eso viene bien y acabado se vale es igual que aquí no esto
no es un ejercicio de optimización podemos decir serio simplemente para para ver cuál salía mejor
y ya está y el que sale mejor es el que ya ha elegido que es 375 y 15 a mes y 15 me sonaba
a las 15 pero ves el 375 porque era era multiplicada por poco era el número 22 he dicho
22 era no no era 22 20 20 20 está al final el chandelier mira ahora los lo voy a poner
chandelier más temporal vale 25 vale este es al final era tr por el número de atrs vale y
eso se lo resta entonces claro si no si no le doy un poco de margen lo hago de acuerdo entonces
eso los tendenciales necesitan un poco de espacio lo que decía de stops trailing pero un poco amplios
lo podría ir en la diapositiva no porque si no no le vas a dejar que corra vale este mira
como tengo el indicador aquí os lo puedo os lo puedo poner chandelier que lo tengo para ver
estatus son vamos a quitar las polinger para no liar vale vamos a quitar todo para no liar
se vea mejor y este que era 275 y periodo era periodo 32 no ya está puesto bien vale este
es cuando veáis que sale por el por el chandelier que hay veces que no es este que pone ser el 4
es por tiempo es por tiempo esto al final suele ser bien porque al final muchas veces aquí por
ejemplo no corría más pero habitualmente en los mercados son cíclicos y tú coges un número de
barras y para bien y para mal muchas veces ya ya está veces oye yo me quedo en este caso 15 días y
ya está y antes me voy protegiendo vale por si va mal pero mientras me quedo 15 días vale aquí
por ejemplo me ha salido por revés porque al final el chandelier este tiene cierto margen claro
con salida por tiempo tener en cuenta que el chandelier debe actuar poco debe actuar poco la
mayoría de veces lo saca el tiempo lo saca el tiempo si ahora mira para que actúe le pongo
al valor del chandelier bueno pongo el chandelier solo que era el chandelier solo era el 12 al 12
pongo el chandelier solo bueno antes antes este ya a ver porque eso me parece que iba bastante bien
este va bastante más sólido más sólido ya al final al meter al meter tiempo ves frontaje de
aciertos se va para arriba es decir le quitas totalmente la capacidad tendencial pero cuidado
que no quiere decir que no sea bueno repito vale quiere decir que no sea bueno es otro tipo de
sistema que no tendrá colas tan largas más estable estable si ahora vamos al chandelier
original que es el 12 12 y le pongo 275 igual 275 no era 275 para que esté configurado igual
que la banda ahora sí que me sale por la banda lo veis no a veces cuando llega aquí la banda
para que se vea en alguno es ahí sale la banda es que ahora solo puede salir por la banda es decir
no tiene ninguna otra salida no tiene la media entonces le devuelve 275 no puede salir por
objetivo este es un poco pobre en el sentido de que al final bueno no es pobre en el sentido
tendencial es bueno es bueno al final te deja correr mucho pero seguramente en valor absoluto
no gana tanto y ese es un poquito más a broto pero si sigue estando muy bien la verdad sigue
estando muy bien gana creo que menos que antes pero está está muy bien también para porque este
el impuro es el impuro y lo deja lo deja correr aquí ves ya ha bajado de 50 vale ya bajado de 50
porque ya digamos que tiene más carácter tendencial más carácter tendencial aquí sí que va siempre
a que vuelva de acuerdo así no vuelve pues no sale él se queda dentro este es un stop muy tendencial
vale muy tendencia aquí lo deja correr o dejar correr hasta que vuelve hasta que vuelve aquí no
vale vale hacemos una pequeña pausita de cinco minutos y ya está y ya está como el relojito
ahora ponemos ahí la sirenita ahí 20 y ya está pues acabamos ahora que tenéis que ir a ver el
madrid y yo al sitio de toda la vida desde pequeñito desde pequeñito desde pequeñito
toda la vida toda la vida de todos los equipos de manchester del sitio desde pequeñito y estamos
ya por aquí han pasado los cinco minutitos tenemos ya la grabación en marcha de nuevo
estamos donde estábamos bueno aquí podemos ahora mientras mira mientras como antes le
he cargado ya unas variables por defecto voy a sacar esto lo voy a volver a cargar
no hombre supongo que es referir al de cauffman lo que pasa que ese libro no se encuentra en
casallana ya tienen métodos creo que se llama es un libro muy recomendable en inglés es una traducción
en español es lamentable hay mucho material y os lo recomiendo mucho vale entonces aquí simplemente
que he hecho ya ahora metido esto no sé con cuál cargado 17 a ver así como quedaba así como
quedaba mejor cual queda mejor así porque antes lo he estudiado con el con las con la salida de su
media de acuerdo ahora le he quitado la media con lo cual la cosa cambia cambia un poco claro porque
la media le hace trailing entonces todos los que no le siguen el precio penaliza mucho más
que antes antes antes tenías ese coche de trailing por tanto las salidas directamente por tp o incluso
por stop y a bruto pues tenían esa ventaja de no salir tan penalizadas ahora en cambio los
estos directivos son salen seguramente muy penalizados al no poder salir por arriba o por
un trailing que es lo suyo no bien tenemos también pendiente ahora vamos un poquito que también hemos
estado trabajando un poquito el main en mil reversión aquí ahora quería quería pasa que no se va a
dar tiempo pero voy a tratar de hacer todo lo que quería si si aquí ahora simplemente por ver un
poco como quedaba la cosa el 6 profit a terre muy interesante interesante si si profit a terre es
el que le da más profit pero si ya te digo tiene un punto bastante importante sobre optimización
no pensar que esto puede ir así directamente esto es un ejercicio teórico para que veáis
cómo usar las salidas y cómo tener software de que te ayude un poco a probar varias cosas
directamente sin tener que hacer todos los sistemas en uno no sino un poco por partes
de acuerdo esto esto es interesante antes no sé si alguien preguntaba por el máster y creo que
esa del máster y que hay un ejercicio de eso de elementos precreados es un poco los elementos
precreados en ese lenguaje es una manera muy útil o sea hay un montón de estrategias todas
el parabólico por ejemplo está hecho entrada o sea todo está hecho entrada y salida y un montón
de esto o sea yo esto lo he hecho en un código pero realmente sueltos están todos toda la mayoría
de salidas están hechas incluso incluso para aunque no las uses para ver el código y aprender
de ellos una maravilla realmente eso tiene tiene muchísimo muchísima ventaja tener sesión y
plataforma genial para empezar a fran tenía vale las que tengo rojas y disculpar que se me había
se me habían colado que ver con eso el trailing de una media desplazada el trailing de una media
no la media puede ser una salida de hecho está está creo que es a 32 tenemos una media móvil a
desplazar no soy mi amigo de desplazar no no soy mi amigo de desplazar no te sé decir no tengo
mucha experiencia en ello fran como para darte una opinión tan contundente como si acopla más o
menos no te puedo decir la verdad a una tema una triple exponencia al momento que es decir yo yo
hace tiempo la verdad pero hemos yo he hecho varios estudios sobre medias nunca he encontrado nada
demasiado concluyente ni tan sólo de la exponencial que conceptualmente dices joder qué bien que limp
parece todo muy lógico he encontrado significativa diferencia con la simple sabes entonces no sé
tema tema no sé casi antes exploraría las medias adaptativas entiendes que es la vez hoy más o sea
las medias adaptativas por ejemplo una muy conocida escama que es que es del de nuestro amigo que
hablamos antes cauman cauman moving average pero hay varias incluso una se llama adaptative
moving average son del palo vale es decir son son del son del estilo pero pero sí que las
adaptativas tienen tienen su moving average adaptatives también tienes la mamá tienes las
tienes la tema que es de mesa esa es un proveedor de software muy muy conocido hay un montón a ver
como todo pues lo puedes explorar todas todas no has explorado la verdad la fama por ejemplo no
le no he explorado la veo aquí ahora y no la he explorado no sé ni qué es la fama vale entonces
bueno pues es adaptativas hay varias al final normalmente normalmente pues utilizan la volatilidad
para adaptarse los criterios ya te digo a mí la de cama me gustaba bastante yo de hecho operé
mucho tiempo en un institucional un sistema una vez ratio una vez ratio que en vez de estar
calculado con la media siempre estaba calculado con la cama iba mucho mejor iba mucho mejor
iba mucho mejor porque las bandas tendían a no se separaban tanto la baja no este efecto
que tiene siempre la banda de bollinger no este efecto que tiene siempre la banda la banda de
bollinger a ver un momentito que voy aquí a cambiar esto este efecto no cuando hay mucha
volatilidad cuando no pasa ves este efecto no este efecto de aquí este efecto de aquí cuando el
precio cae muy la baja otra tal y muy se aleja muchísimo tarda mucho en volver no con la cama
se mítica bastante recuerdo una media me gustaba me gustaba pero ahora sí porque no la que no
operamos pero es una de esas cosas ahí pendientes y apuntadas apuntadas para para para mirar vale
porque sí que puede tener su su interés puede tener su interés vale entonces ya te digo más
exploraría por medias adaptativas que dobles triples no sé si sin decir que no todo se puede
investigar y todo todo es bien a nivel de investigación vale pero ya te digo no normalmente
me he quedado bastante en la simple porque no he encontrado claras ventajas de otras y al final
en caso de duda simplicidad siempre están en caso de duda simplicidad eso grabatelo con fuego si no
lo ves muy claro bueno dices para hacer un trailing sí porque no porque no sí sí porque no dependerá
un poco de la entrada eso que te decía el parabólic puede ir bien pero en el bollinger no es muy
adecuado porque el bollinger en tendencial es una entrada muy retrasada con lo bueno y malo que eso
trae tienes y parabólic es un es un de estos necesitan trabas rápidas de acuerdo es una salida
para entrar rápidas entonces claro pues depende si el concepto media trailing porque no pero tienes
que ver si te aporta más eso que un chandelier o un canal de que es lo que es un canal de mínimos
al final no porque también puedes usar un chandelier con aterrizero es decir puede perfectamente
usarse decir al final un canal de mínimos o de máximos o sea bueno no no no un chandelier
un chandelier al final resta del máximo vale pero puedes usar un canal un canal de don chat para
entendernos lo puede usar de stop no puede usarle stop vale entonces bueno lo que decía aquí por
ejemplo imaginarnos ahora como estamos en un periodo similar a los de materias primas venga
vamos a poner oro no lo he mirado me estoy tirando un triple de no del otro campo no de
fuera del estadio me estoy tirando un triple de fuera del estadio así que fijaros como está
bajando datos ahora veremos mientras baja datos nos vamos aquí al reversal vale cambio de tercio
para para dar una vuelta una vuelta rápida vale esto es el tendencia el me el reverso de intradiliario
que teníamos en multicharts trabajado vale que hicimos algunas pruebas con él y bueno pues hemos
tratado también jugando un poquito con las con las salidas esto estaba alberto antes dándole dándole
caña y bueno era un sistema que ya estaba ya tenía alguna alguna situación aprovechable que
es un se puede partir perfectamente de él se puede buscar más es que hay mil mil opciones de pivots
por ejemplo si días no nos faltaba nunca como ya os hablé de revistas os hablé de demás y al
final sí que me gustaría en algún de alguna manera acabar dando algunas ideas más como para
para que pudierais trabajar vosotros ya pos curso no pero bueno esto ya lo iremos viendo las cuatro o
no sé si cuatro o cinco gracias que que me quedan las toque ir preparando bien aquí tenemos nuevamente
un poco el mismo sistema que ya vimos pero con aplicando el módulo de salidas que habéis visto
ahora de acuerdo a partir de ahí pues nuevamente lo puedes trabajar si tú tienes un código con
muchas salidas aquí lo que puedes hacer es bloquear las salidas vale por un poco iba a decir cuenta
la vieja no es decir al final como no se pensó así el sistema porque se podría esto la María
la manera buena de hacerla es ponerle una variable true false y en el código le pones salidas true
salidas false se entiende es decir le pones aquí y quiero salidas no vale den no y pones la variable
quiero salidas control false y ya está de acuerdo sería la manera un poco más limpia de hacerlo hoy
que hemos hecho pues le hemos hecho un corchete y hemos comentado toda la parte de salidas y a
tomar bien toda la manera la manera es rápida y fácil de hacerlo comentado entonces el sistema
ahora no tiene salidas de acuerdo el bowling de intradía no tiene salidas vale para automáticamente
usar las salidas que hemos aplicado aquí ya está desde haber todo antes ha estado investigando un
poco se me está saliendo algún aviso por ahí y tenemos este informe de utilización que ha hecho
alberto facilito bueno esto no tarda mucho alberto más hecho no pues me voy a meter un sortino vale
porque a mí ha salido así coño pero como no lo habías elegido si no lo eliges también sale no
sabía pensaba que lo tenías que elegir para salir no no pero que pensaba que no lo calculaba
si lo tienes ahí lo calcula a tu que ha aprendido algo y alberto ha aprendido algo aquí hay algunas
que deben ser incoherentes no porque están con muy buenos no bueno la realidad es bastante
estabilidad que excepto unas bastante estables todas no muy muy antitenencial con tal aquí
que números que números tenemos y tenemos la 13 y la 22 no que están saliendo más tope mira
aquí te está saliendo la banda de bólinger contraria qué curioso qué curioso la banda pero
pero este este es pero cómo cómo sale la banda bólinger contraria si es a bueno claro porque
es este p este p no en qué parámetro está a ver qué parámetro está es interesante esto pero
voy a quitar voy a quitar cosas de aquí para ganar un poco de ganar un poco no se lo sé
salir en la banda contraria es la lógica sí sí sí efectivamente salir en la banda contraria
en este caso es bastante lógico ahí lo tienes claro entra antitenencial y la banda contraria
te saca para que se está bastante filtrado bueno porque está eso está en cinco minutos era no
en 30 30 sí pero continuo claro salir en la banda contraria es bien es bien sí sí sí salir en la
banda contraria costumbra ser bien y no tiene ninguna otra salida en este caso y es curioso
que le salga la mejor esa no sí bueno luego también estaba la 22 13 era esta y la 22 es
bólinger con esto porcentual bólinger con esto porcentual no y además con un número de tres
realmente elevado por número de tres bastante bastante elevado esto porque no le hemos dejado
otro sample creo no pero dejando la otra sample hubiera estado bastante guapo hay que hay que
mirarlo porque tiene bastante tiene una muestra muy importante treacher era una muestra muy
importante de trades también estamos ahí con el 12 con el 12 que es el chandelier nuestro gran
amigo chandelier que invitarle algo chandelier un día al mono de chan a mono de chan hay que
meterle hay que invitarlo algo me gusta mucho chandelier a mí 8 trailing aterra muy bien
el trailing que es muy bien también va bien ante el final simplemente es coherente acompaña
el precio de acuerdo lo único dimensionar siempre en este tipo de cosas por mucho que yo os sigo
recomendando encarecidamente que no os dejéis llevar por no que no os dejéis llevar por por
el tema de los números para elegir valor absoluto o porcentual vale hay que ajustarlo
de acuerdo a la base de datos sino no tiene sentido que salga peor vale y cuidado con la
optimización en este tipo de cosas es decir los trailing tienen fama de acoplar y es verdad pero
también porque a veces nos pasamos de acuerdo a ver no hace falta optimizar el 001 es decir mirar
evaluar las variaciones lo que os expliqué cuando hicimos la revisión de apolo nosotros lo tuvimos
que cambiar si yo estoy aquí utilizando este atr o este tal de 0 25 0 25 comprobar que no lo
he hecho ahora pero para que lo sepáis comprobar si variar de 0 25 tiene sentido o realmente
variar de 0 25 es demasiado poco donde es decir que tiene que tener una significación cambiar de
cada incremento del valor en una variable que yo pase por un optimizador tiene que tener sentido
son los mapas se ve muy bien vale los mapas se ve muy bien que habría que hacer el mapa todo todo
todo esto hay que hacerlo todo vale decir aquí estamos un poco rastreando investigando vale esto
estaría entre la teoría insistí mucho en ello y me repito es decir lógicamente tú para explicarlo
tienes que explicarlo como un proceso pero muchas veces es todo un uno y donde vas y vienes arriba
y atrás acuerdo no necesariamente es pam papam esto está evidentemente en investigación evaluación
preliminar y también evaluación es decir está un poco a caballo pero más en evaluación preliminar
que en evaluación más en evaluación preliminar que en evaluación pero que también tiene mucha
importancia y hay veces que la evaluación preliminar pasa ya la evaluación limpio ya cepilladito y
limpio es decir muy ya simplemente con alguna prueba de estrés mapa en algunos casos wall
forward etcétera vale ya probar un poquito estresar el sistema para ver cómo se mueve de acuerdo
cómo se mueve en ese en esas pruebas finales vale bien pues vamos a ver si nuestro amigo
oro ha acabado de cargar parece que sí parece ser parece ser que sí y tenemos aquí el sistema
tal como estaba puesto antes en el petróleo m7 20 rato el ratón me dice que no tiene pilas
pues aguanta un poco el favor hazme el favor de aguantar un poco venga no sé esto como está
directo como está así es mal está mal es un churro patatero así ahora mismo molenga el oro es
un activo que es tendencial pero también es antitenercial gracias gracias es tendencial
pero también es antitenercial tiene esa particularidad de ir bien en ambos en ambos
entornos realmente aquí va muy tarde con esta banda de bolíguez no sé cuánto tengo puesta
o tengo 20 por efecto o le hice un estudio esto antes le tengo 22 que tengo 22 no tengo 22 y
dos desviaciones que es un mes tengo puesto un mes está cargado en el change bueno vamos a ver si
con las salidas podemos hacer algo aparentemente hay poco que rascar aquí aparentemente poco que
rascar pero vamos a ver si nos da una pista no creo que nos dé una pista de por dónde va a ir
mejor alguno que vaya muy muy bien pero sí que nos va a poder dar una pista de por dónde van los
tiros por dónde van los tiros y por dónde puede mejorar está por donde las salidas pueden un poco
respirar a ver las salidas es respirar porque no sé cuál estaba puesta mejor estaba puesta
una condicionada si parece que saca alguna que gana vamos a verse aquí con los datos que habíamos
obtenido el petróleo no olvidemos tenemos algo bueno alguno ha salido verde alguno ha salido verde
sólo mejora tocando las las salidas 23 y 10 vale 23 y 10 parabólic curiosamente curiosamente el
parabólic curiosamente el parabólic y luego el 10 es al cierre puesto es raro muy muy mala señal
y 18 y 18 el chandelier compró el porcentual bueno habría habría que ver habría que ver
alguno de estos y hasta de trabajarlo un poquito entendés mirar a ver qué inputs tiene porque
es posible que la volatilidad de más de del oro no sé no se active no tenga mucho sentido también
es verdad que mucha gente reacia yo no lo soy de verdad porque me parece que es vital para adaptar
a las bandas de bollinger si hay muestra no en el diario en el diario es más complicado pero si tú
vas en el intradía tienes margen de tocar el periodo podéis tocar los periodos no tengáis
tampoco no no hagamos tampoco cosas muy raras vale pero puedes tocar si hay muestra y si lo permiten
los grados de libertad de acuerdo porque la volatilidad de un activo viene muy condicionada
por eso vale sobre todo las bandas y a nivel de intradía normalmente las bandas suele ir
mejor abrirlas un poco más hay mucho ruido en un intradía y el tener las mismas desviaciones en
dos hace que salga con más frecuencia aquí parece que le cuesta más salir que al petróleo entonces
pero aunque eso ya pretende ajustarse pues habría que verlo habría que verlo pero aquí pues mira
con el parabólic en este caso le va le va mejor se levanta mejor sin haber tocado nada
simplemente las entradas y dejando el parabólic ha mejorado algo sigue siendo bastante churro que
nada es nulamente aprovechable así pero en el lado largo fijaros que ya ha empezado a tener datos
bastante positivos el lado largo de hecho muy positivos muy positivos en el largo está muy bien
en el largo está muy bien pero en el corto está rotísimo sirva fatal en el corto así que no nos
da para y es verdad que como dice es mejor trabajarlo con reglas simétricas así que deberíamos de darle
más más vueltas bollinger en nave rathion que es esta combinación es una es una ventana de operativa
muy cerrada es decir no es una ahí sistemas cual que yo sigo por ejemplo las reglas de apolo que
es una especie de mail reversión tendencial raro pero a estrapola bastantes activos a ver
rathion no a ver rathion la idea de bollinger tendencial requiere activos muy tendenciales
muy volátiles no no le da y el oro sí que lo ha sido muchos años pero fijaros aquí si yo ahora
abro el histórico la cantidad de periodo que tenéis ahí ahogado es decir igual que os decía
que antes la bolsa de ser más mil reversión también ha mejorado a nivel tendencial el oro le
ha pasado lo contrario se dirá ha empeorado de tendencial a mil reversión manteniendo un
poco las dos vertientes pero pasó años muy muy tendenciales ahora de hecho las últimas
meses está volviendo un poco está volviendo un poco y está mejorando ese ese nivel pero le
cuesta le cuesta un enfoque como este tan tan tendencial que necesita colas tan largas le
cuesta mucho de acuerdo le cuesta hay mejor me cuesta mucho porque sí que tiene tramos
bastante limpios pero luego también tiene tramos de congestión bastante durilla y le
cuesta mucho muchas idas y venidas muchas ideas y venidas bueno pues lo vamos si no sé alguna
pregunta más o se le contestó yo a jose mira porque a veces optimizamos por tse y otras por
ppc bueno no sé si es que no has acabado la teoría jose pero en la teoría hablamos de esto
nosotros en tres son utilizamos por los tres siempre optimizamos por los tres y buscamos
equilibrio cuando utilizamos por multicharts normalmente usamos sortino aunque también
tenemos ulcer y también tenemos csi también tenemos expectancy score y tenemos una especie
de performance calculado pero a mí me gusta mucho sortino entonces como en multicharts lo
tengo calculado tanto para sistemas como para portfolios pues lo lo tengo ahí desde aquí tengo
el sortino también te cochar el ulcer entonces a veces mira solemos hacer varias podemos hacer
en multicharts vamos a hacer el sortino y ulcer vale y en ahora actualmente y en multicharts
solemos hacer tse y s y ppc y las cruzamos vale es decir en los exes acordaros que es
lo solo lo habéis visto la teoría 100% está en la teoría 100% comentado vamos a decir la lección
pero pero está comentado así lo hacemos nosotros se puede hacer en tres eso por ejemplo podrías
usar la api pero nosotros nos hemos hecho y hacer hacer una mezcla de los tres eso creo
que sí que se podía pero vimos seguía teniendo algunas limitaciones y no lo abordamos porque
no le vimos tanta ventaja hacerlo vale qué más qué más bueno mira este este código voy a ver
aquí me dejaba subir porque ya me parece que ya tuve ese problema y no un archivo doc gif no no
aquí no dejaba tuve ese problema lo tuvo que subir al disco no porque si tampoco me metes no me deja
vale pues lo subiré al disco vale para exportado pero vamos a meter el que hemos dicho antes al
otro cosa que quería mira como veo que llegó 10 minutos se me olvidaba lo voy a hacer en el
de tres es lo que os decía y probar brevemente vale yo aquí ahora tengo a ver ratio bloqueo
esto vale y aquí activo entradas vale yo aquí entradas no sé si lo habéis visto en el código
tengo 5 6 básicas puedes poner las que queráis lo he puesto sólo unas básicas para poderos lo
mostrar aquí metidas tengo una más simple momento que cierre menor que cierre anterior esos
momentos una break out con hay por encima de hay que es anterior vale breakout típico una media
móvil vale aquí está la veras pero si le quieres poner x aberrach o otra veras pues le pones tengo
una entrada de bollinger van pero en antitenencia tengo una entrada de volatilidad es cierre mayor
que cierre anterior más una cantidad de aberrach vale de volatilidad tengo una bollinger antitencia
tengo a mi ratio y tengo una 7 que es un don chan que además he puesto horas por si queréis meterle
horas vale pensado en la intradía que es tipo breakout pero igual que el breakout hace hay por
encima de hay que es a que hace don chan en el sentido puro de en esto es decir by next bar
ad hay que se mete esto para entrar es decir son muy parecidas y deberían dar resultados similares
pero por eso la no sé vamos a probar la 5 por ejemplo volatilidad entre número 5 vale y bueno
aquí puedes un poco jugar o bueno mira vamos a hacer porque eso como estamos en diario nos lo va
nos lo va a permitir hacer a nivel de investigación claro bueno tengo 22 de periodos vale pues lo dejo
ahí el tema es que aquí los stops y tal esto sí que se adapta mucho la volatilidad del activo y
están puestos para el logro entonces habría que verlo un poco como va pero bueno que es igual que
ya digo esto es para para darle un poco le pongo de 1 a 7 porque el cero no me vale
7 no tengo 7 no 7 no desde 1 a 7 entrada y de periodo no tocó nada salida le pongo de 0 a 32
periodo no tocó nada y bueno pues no sé esto no no sé no tocó nada tampoco venga y aquí tengo
231 231 yo creo que me va a dar me va a dar en me va a dar en exhaustivas en ningún tipo de
problema ha habido pocas bajas y entiendo por el coseto ahí aquí clavado es jose aquí quieto
ni a la madre ni leches en vinagre nada ojo ojo que te veas salir de la ojo que te veas salir
ahí hay que poner mensajes en el chat de cada minuto esto como cuando le das la condición a
alguien tiene que pasar por el jugador pues igual cada minuto un mensajito en el chat para
comprobar que está lo que es broma por supuesto por supuesto y yo mañana voy a ver el barco
también o sea que no no pasa nada bueno a ver el por curiosidad eso es una ahí no ha sido un ejercicio
absoluto de curiosidad bueno aquí ves ya automáticamente hemos encontrado algunas
cosas decentes de acuerdo decir que se ha adaptado a tal vez parece que la entrada 4
no acuerdo cual era tal pues bueno es esto simplemente a la que veáis líneas de investigar a
mirar es la bolígara bolígara 4 pero en antitenencial caro en antitencial la bolígara
en antitencial le va le va bastante bien y salida con la 3 o con la 11 con varias y luego a nivel
de entradas parece que también la 3 tiene algo que sea mucho peor pensar que luego se
cuenta bajar las salidas filtro se cuenta bajar muchas más cosas simplemente aquí no se trata de
quedarse la mejor es un poco ver cuáles saca algo positivo para partir de ahí empezar a seguir el
hilo pero evidentemente la 4 es muy prometedora porque la 4 fijaros que tiene hasta un montón
de salidas en la 4 apúntatela alberto apúntatela porque no recuerdo haber estudiado al oro con
este con bolígara antitencial y la verdad está sí sí pero fíjate cómo va el cabrito tiene es
bastante prometedora esta entrada bolígara tendencial porque la verdad queda resultados
bastante sólidos vamos a ver si bueno pues a ver a ver y qué salida tiene aquí la salido 3 muy
flojo en el corto pero muy destacado en el largo alberto y bueno y general general pues bueno no
no es mal no es mal se puede mirar se puede se puede mirar tiene datos más que decentes para
un primer para un primer análisis tiene datos más que más que decentes lo que pasa ya ver esta entrada
está entrando bien así claro cuando cruza claro cuando cruza pero está no está no sé por qué
entra aquí a ver si está mal esto 22 entrada 4 a ver código entrada 4 tenemos un close cross
abobo en gerván close periodo entrada en menos 2 y los crows bilobo en gerván en close periodo
entrada pues no tiene mucha mucha historia 22 y al cierre así que al cierre así que
que debería de estar correctas está deshabilitada entrada 4 22 salida 3 22 y la 3 me está usando la
3 es realmente simple la 3 es al final un esto por atr esto por atr y punto ya esto para el
reverse bastante curioso bueno pues la verdad que sí que es prometedor así no está mal no está mal
la verdad no está mal se puede dar una vuelta a esto bueno familia pues sí que lo vamos a ir
dejando aquí añadiremos esto que hemos hecho de añadir y mañana os cuelgo el código este en
en el disco de acuerdo y pues nada más nada más me despido hasta el principio el martes que viene
trabajamos con la idea de hacer preguntas pero es probable como os digo que agenciamos una
posterior que puede estar un mes o mejor más y todo después de acuerdo para acabar de recopilar
dudas que pueden haber y demás vale en fin de hoy por acabada la clase hoy que no sé si era la 12
hasta el martes que viene chao